question for you connor have you noticed
that since you moved to japan you just
start bowing for
everything no but you know what i do do
i do anime reaction noises
no i do the same thing as well yeah and
you're thinking what the [ __ ] that's
weird as [ __ ]
why would you do that like yeah yeah
okay this is why it makes so much sense
now right because whenever
they ask me for like anything at the
supermarket i'm like it's caught off
guard right
yeah yeah you know i'll see myself
it makes total sense why they do it in
anime now now because
i've noticed when uh japanese people
when you're talking to them they need to
make it known that
they're listening yeah so they all like
in in england people just
kind of just stand stand there or just
nod japanese like
hi hi hmm and i've started doing the
same thing as well
whenever someone's talking i'm always
having to make it known that i do that
in interviews and people are like can
you
just shut up for five seconds and just
like the opposite japanese
all right oh yeah i guess we're putting
that at the beginning
and that's the intro go ahead take it
away take it away
what's up you naughty neanderthals
welcome back to another episode of trash
taste podcast i am not gonna stop doing
how long are you sitting on that for was
that like like two seconds
i bet you have a [ __ ] script or just
going through the alphabet
excel sheet exactly i'm like i have to
make an alliteration somehow
so let's just let's just pick a letter
and just roll with it well welcome to
trash taste the show where we talk about
a trash taste and everything else in the
world i'm your host for today joey
and as always we're doing this now we're
probably doing this
okay hello so this episode
uh i thought we would maybe talk about
something i don't know if
it's going to get a little too personal
we'll try not to go too personal route
but you know to go back to the whole
thing about
how we first started talking about him
and how we got into anime we've already
done an episode on that yeah we've
already done our origin story
but how did we meet or how did we make
our first i don't know how to say it
anime friend
is that a thing i don't know okay so i i
have a question for you guys
okay to start this off because we talked
about our anime origin story like how we
got into anime yeah
but when you guys were anime fans
did you have any friends in school or
anything or
how did you guys deal with that because
i was a closet anime fan
yeah i was a complete closet anime fan
for all of
school but yeah but yeah i think that's
a british thing though like i got i got
rinsed for playing video games so like
imagine if i came out and was like
this i like this i like animations this
is my new thing now
i like these drawn two dt's can you
believe i got mocked for playing video
games in school and now it's just like
the accepted past time right i
got so much [ __ ] for that that's weird
because in my school
video games were quite normalized was it
just your school
maybe did you no no i got rinsed to my
school unless you're playing
fifa or cod there was and i still got
rid
what like i would be sitting in my room
in university playing some rpg
hoping that nobody opens the door to
discover the fact that i was playing
i was playing jrpgs i think if i came
out
saying that i was a massive jrpg fan
where i was you know playing persona 3
or something
yeah i probably would have gotten beaten
up as well but i got so much [ __ ] for
playing runescape and i still to this
day
really i think i love runescape i
remember some videos popped up in my
recommended recently and i had a great
time watching them
because i got because in my school i
think my my group of friends we were
more so than not i guess like the the
nerdy group of friends yeah so we so
a lot of my friends from high school got
me into games like like runescape
like starcraft uh you know other just
like land games like civilization like
those games back in the day but when it
came to anime
i think i had a really tough time
because i was literally the only
asian kid in my school oh no same way i
was the only asian kid in my school with
like any amount of asian
like i'm not even like full blood asian
but it's just like oh
this boy's a little bit oriental
he's rice what the hell yeah so i i was
i think i was a closet anime fan for
man i want to say like majority of my
high school life
but then my group of friends who got me
into like starcraft and runescape i was
like okay you guys are nerdy enough
maybe i can try and convince them to
watch something and i convinced one of
my friends to watch ava
oh so i was like why ava that's not
really the uh
gateway anime i would think of don't
know maybe because i
was recently re-watching ava yeah and i
thought okay this is probably
normie enough no that they could maybe
be kidding
recommending ava as someone's first
anime that could go one of two ways
yeah and there's no there's gonna be no
middle ground either he's going to think
this is amazing and
he's a fan but the thing is i didn't
want to get them into like
naruto or one piece or dragon ball to
start with because
we all know if your gateway anime is one
piece
naruto or dragon you're gonna be
announcing all you're gonna be talking
about for the rest of your career so
hey man i don't know man i mean i got in
through naruto
but i mean i remember the point you got
it i got it i got it
there there was there was the point when
i would only watch shonen and i know
exactly the exact phase you're talking
about yeah
and then you figure out that huh there's
other things
outside of shonen that are pretty cool
in this medium
and some people i guess just never
figure that out i feel like
naruto fans are like the british with
food it's like no no no potatoes is
all we need spice what is that about
what is about what is it about like it's
not
obviously not all shown in fans but a
lot of shonen fans who
as as you said like get into say naruto
and yeah just
exclusively talk about naruto's like
what is it i want to know what their
mentality is right with anime where it's
like do they just think that
everything that's not naruto is just
hentai like
there's like no no there's no in-between
it's either shonan or just like straight
up
r18 [ __ ] they're like what is it what is
this high school romance [ __ ]
i don't want to feel i want to feel i
want to feel one emotion and that's hype
i'm like show jokes
it must be the thing of like i get it
cause the type is [ __ ] but like just
they just
must want hype their whole life just
being like a crack addict yeah right
like you you only want to feel that high
you get from crack it's like it's like
steroids this is just the same
like yo e3 it was crazy this year every
game every game i'm hyped for every game
and then they don't play any of them
like the next modern warfare yeah but in
the moment there's like a bad
news article about the game that just
came out in e3 they're like yeah i knew
it was [ __ ]
the whole time the whole time yeah no so
like my anime friend
i got so there was a group of them i was
like me and maybe
like i'd say like six or seven guys who
i used to like really really closely
hang out with in high school
and i got one of my friends who got me
into like starcraft
i got him to watch ava and i i wanted to
try that just with one person i didn't
want to like bring
a whole group of people into the guys
group viewing so i kind of was just like
any meaning
i got you watch ava and he was like okay
i'll give it a go
and he was kind of mere about it at
first i like
i like anime and i i was like at points
like kinda like yeah
and that was the moment where i was like
oh gateway anime are important
and ava is not that always
yeah so i think i think that one friend
he he watched ava
and then he eventually found death note
yeah yeah and he and and one piece and
those like the two shows that he heavily
gone into so i was like okay
then maybe i can try it out with the
other boys hey watch death now watch one
piece
there was boys before us these are the
og boys
do you know what the do you know what
the name of our like this is going to be
really cringy but
that we had like a group name what was
the name joey it was the
[Music]
we were called hbk because we were
did you guys ever play handball in
school i think that's an australian
i think that's an australian thing so in
australian schools we play handball but
not like the olympic sport handle like
like
school grounds handball but usually most
kids in australia
stop playing handball by around like
sixth grade right so it's very rarely
you go into middle school
and play handball we played handball all
the way until high school graduation
and we were the only ones and so from
nowhere we were called hbk which is the
handball crew
[Laughter]
and we were through with the k you were
the cause and and
it's not like and and it was just out of
nowhere one day
just the other boys in our year just saw
us playing handball and they were like
hbk
and we're like what the [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] does that mean we later found that
man handball crew
and normal people would be like oh
that's [ __ ] cringy yeah we were like
handbook hell yeah
i think i think handball is something
i've only heard australians play in
their school
because oh yeah i've seen obviously he's
seen handball in the olympics and
everything like yeah
when we had like a british team like
when did they play that i know right but
it's completely different to the olympic
sport yeah so so when i saw handball
because i'd always known handball as
that thing that you play in school
where it's like four white squares and
you kind of like yeah it's it's
basically just tennis but with your hand
yeah and a tennis ball and in really
confined space so when i saw handball
the olympic sport i was like what the
[ __ ] is this
this is a handball no it's really
interesting to hear you say going back
to the anime um
conversation that we were having because
i didn't even make my first anime friend
till i started youtube like that was
years after i started youtube i i didn't
start
talking to other people who liked anime
until
the age of the internet where i
literally started talking to other
people who reviewed anime
right right because back when i was in
school and especially when i was in
university
i did everything i could to keep it
under wraps
like this even in uni even in uni it was
like
top secret confidential if you find this
out
i'm i'm i'm gonna change my identity or
something like that
i remember someone walked into my room
of me watching no game no life in
university and
it was the moment of like how do i how
do i explain
what's going on here because one of the
bad scenes as well i'm like
i i have a really similar story so
so in uni we're you know first year of
university
uh in england at least we have this
thing called freshest week where you
basically
go out every night and get pissed and
very very drunk get very very drunk and
just go clubbing sounds awesome yeah so
me being
the you know socially awkward nerd that
i was back then um i would still try to
go out as much as i could but yeah i
mean
he can get tiring off you know six or
seven days of just
pure clubbing every day man that that
[ __ ] gets to you yeah yeah
it was a lot man yeah i don't know how
people do it and people would like look
forward to it
the next year i know i'm like i don't
know how i i feel 30
already in this in this one week of
freshers so this one night i was just in
a club
and i wasn't even that drunk because
you'd be i'd been drinking
five or six days before that yeah and so
i was just in the middle of this darn
floor
dance floor and i just had like this
epiphany i'm having a [ __ ] time i'd
rather be watching
i'd rather be watching anime right now
like i was just that one guy who just
danced in a club and just had the this
is [ __ ]
that's literally every time i go to the
club yeah i'm like i need more drinks
so so instead of getting more drinks i'm
just like you know what i'm gonna [ __ ]
off and go home and watch some bloody
anime
and i didn't tell anyone that i was
[ __ ] off back home
so i i go find myself like that you're
that guy in uni
yeah yeah i'm the lone wolf don't talk
to me
yeah i just want i just wanted to watch
some anime and
what the [ __ ] am i doing in a club when
i could be watching some big fat
animated
which is exactly what i did on a t-shirt
i i i
i go back to my room and as you do in
uni you
yeah you know unlike americans in in
england we have our own
private rooms so we don't dream
yeah yeah exactly so i have this reward
to myself and as you do i take off my
trousers because
as a guy it's you're just more
comfortable in your boxes
you just are okay jeans are way too
restrictive so
take off my trousers start sitting down
turn on my laptop and put on the episode
of monogatari
huh the toothbrush no no it was the
shower scene with
syndra oh yeah so it was like episode
two and i was really getting into this
wait what do you mean getting here and i
was like no no because it was morning
it's morning guttery it's a good
it's a good series okay it's a good
scene
how sober are you at this point like i
fully sober i was like that's when they
feel i was like a little bit tipsy but i
was i was
you know i was just having a good time
because you know when you haven't
watched anime in a while
and it just feels good to watch anime
after that anime drought yeah i was just
oh man this this is just a nice break
from all the drinking and clubbing and
socializing
and all that stuff yeah and as soon as
it gets to the shower scene i just hear
this
door creak open like
[Music]
and then i look around and then one of
my
flatmates is just staring at me and i
turn around
and it's just me and my boxers watching
and all he sees is just cinderella's
massive tits
on screen taking a shower and i try i
try to eye him up to be like
this isn't what it looks like and he
eyes me back saying oh [ __ ] this is
exactly what it looks like
you should have asserted maintain eye
contact and then and then i just he just
closes the door
and i'm just like okay i'm moving to
china now
he knows he knows my secrets and then he
just never
spoke to me again i i have a way worse
story than that okay
um it was it was again like during high
school when
i'd gotten like that the one friend that
i got him into ava
so he unlike everybody else like
everybody kind of got into anime like
i i did i was closeted for a while but i
kind of was like
i need to get out of the closet so
i need to i need to try and convince my
friends
that this is an okay thing to watch so
you need to make a youtube video saying
i'm coming out yeah
i'm coming out i like anime yeah exactly
right
so the one friend that the the guy i
first experimented on
uh he he why are you going to use this
this terminology jerry to explain it
i was experimenting he's just like like
yoga me being
planning every step being like hmm okay
if i show them this anime maybe
they'll like it's like maybe one of them
will like get into it and sure enough
one of them got into it so i was just
like kick
dory so i got so he
just my one friend he really really got
into anime
i'm talking like him and i would come to
school every week
and we would discuss the episodes that
just came out like the night before like
yeah him and i were like
full-on like anime buddies and one night
we were we were drinking at a friend's
place
and uh and i and obviously you know as
you do when you're in high school you
get really shit-faced right of course um
and i was staying at his place and i had
like missed the bus home and everything
so i was like all right i'm just gonna
crash at yours
and it was just him and i and we were
like we should watch some anime like you
know just why not let's just watch some
anime
and he's uh and i don't know how it came
to it but we were just kind of
scrolling through just looking for
something to watch and he's like you
watch this no you watch this now
and uh and i just kind of slowly turned
to him just as a gag i was like
you ever heard of kisses oh no
and he's like no what's that and he's
like i'm like we should check it out
let's just watch one episode just for
shits and giggles let's let's watch an
episode of kisses
so imagine he just me and my friend
sitting in a room just you know six feet
apart because we're not gay
so we're just watching just just bonding
over an episode of kisses just bonding
over an episode like every incest
moment happens in like porn and it was
worse because
we didn't i don't know how long he was
standing at the door but his little
brother
was standing at the door he was just
watching us watch kisses and we were
like
into it too we were like oh hell yeah
like we were like
these kids that like mike was out mind
you we were very drunk
so we were like oh i was like who's your
favorite and he's like oh man they're
both
really cute and just you know full of
like you you would have thought we were
like making a reaction video we were
like
full on commentating the entire thing oh
my god
and what was supposed to be just you
know just for shoots and giggles just
one episode of kisses we binged the
entire series in one night
what yeah oh my god did he enjoy it he
loved it
and that and that was the moment where i
was like this guy's excited
if joe don't don't go home with joey
drunk yeah he'll try and show you shitty
oh yeah i've done that i like the fact
that you had to wait until he was alone
and yeah because because these other
boys were like
discussing you know how good the
alabaster rock in one piece was and i'm
like i don't think these boys are ready
for kisses
these these guys are like these guys are
one level one thief and these guys are
like level 10 mafia boss right so i was
like let's let's let's
experiment with joe joey's like the
sensei who sees the hidden potential in
that one student
he's like i i can teach you the way
didn't you
you're ready to learn you're ready to
upgrade so did he
so did he enjoy more of that kind of
show afterwards so then
so then that was the point where we
basically
him and i we found out that we found out
from each other that we're into
those kinds of shows or we're okay with
that we're just
into each other yeah we were just into
those kinds of shows
yeah because after we finished kisses
we're both just like
i gotta i just gotta let you know bro
now that we've had this [ __ ] like
journey together
that i'm like secretly into these shows
he's like
every single moment of this story could
be like a coming out to each other
and he was like dude i'm kind of into
these shows
and then from there and from doing this
on purpose
and dude i'm kind of injured
and yeah so so from then that point on i
i kind of was i became a lot more open
with like my my
my your your my my trashy taste in anime
right sure
joey's like yes i'm hentai sexy i'm
right are you purposely picking words
this is free real estate all right like
go go for it but
yeah but that was the point where i i
slowly realized oh
if i'm closeted then yeah i'll obviously
have a lot of fun you know just
kind of enjoying this medium for myself
but yeah there's a whole other enjoyment
when you get someone else into it as
well
i know i remember the first time i was
able to have conversations about anime
with other people and that was just
so liberating for me yeah that i had
spent
all of these years enjoying this medium
but have literally
nobody to talk to it about yeah and then
i made youtube videos to be like okay
if i can't have anyone to talk to about
i'm just gonna talk to the void
and hopefully someone will listen and i
remember having the some of the first
genuine conversations
online because it had to be online back
then um about shows that i liked and it
just
i just felt free yeah yeah because um
yeah i don't know who your first friend
in uh in like the anime youtube sphere
was
for me it was uh probably horden reviews
and
the people from what's potaku we're
going going way back then
i think mine might have been misty your
yours missed it
a lot of them were just like fleeting
you know mutuals you know yeah
i'd say you guys probably the first
proper friends that i i made outside
that first
you know yeah because it was it was
strange for me because i'm i'm the
complete opposite when it comes to
my friend circle on youtube where you
would think that
i would be very quick to bond with other
antitubers
once starting an anime youtube channel
yeah weirdly enough for like the first
two years or so i was only friends with
gaming youtubers
yeah but that's also because i was doing
a lot of gaming stuff alongside stuff
and i think it honestly might have been
misty that was the first like proper
anna tuber
and that was when i discovered this
entire community of antitubers i was
like oh my god i'm not the only one
yeah there are other people who do this
stuff as well and then that's when i
kind of to
drift away from more of the gaming stuff
and focus on what my channel was
actually about
yeah yeah i remember i i realized we get
comments sometimes that are like
me listening to the podcast and it's
like that guy sitting next to me
it's great because i remember i was
doing my a levels i remember listening
to paul taku actually oh i'm about to
listen to it yeah
i would do my i remember i have this
distinct memory of you guys arguing i
don't know
what but i was doing over a lot of
things yeah i was doing my math a levels
i was and i remember just listening to
it and i was like man and i want to like
be in that and talk to them i don't have
friends i want to like talk to friends
about anime because i know even at that
point when i was like
like 17 i still had no one to talk to
about anime yeah
and uh i didn't really make friends
until university but
i got banned from my uh anime uh
club facebook group because they were
talking about like housing abridged and
i was like oh [ __ ] i voiced in there i
said in the comments i was like oh yeah
i voiced
it and then they banned me they thought
i was lying
because they were like they're like why
would someone in our university you know
first year
voicing in housing bridge and then i
went to the club and i explained
that like it's like two months later
yeah i i happened to go there anyway
and i was like yeah can you like unban
me from the club i don't know why you
guys banned me
and they're like oh we don't know i'm
like i know i know you [ __ ] know why
we can't we can't have someone having
clout yeah i do
i i was in that group for like a year
and i made one comment about that i got
immediately banned [ __ ] you swansea
so you joined the anime club in
university then i joined i paid the two
two pound a year membership and then all
they did was watch ghibli movies
and like that's all they did i like this
i joined the anime called my universe's
biggest mistake it's like it's weird
because it's like a mixture of like
it's a mixture of people who like don't
really care about anime and like one or
two people who are way too into it or
into really different niches so
yeah i felt like i don't know i couldn't
really talk with none of them watched
the same [ __ ] i watched yeah
um and it's the same with gaming like
the gaming club in my uni was like
supposed to be
gaming and it was orange magic the
gathering
well i mean it's type of gaming it's
type of game you think a gaming club
yeah they're diverse files yeah yeah and
i was like well i guess i'm not joining
any clubs in unis
brony club it is i'm trying to get oh go
i was gonna say like i made a whole
video on it like a while ago but i i
joined
i joined the anime club there was one
anime club at sydney uni
and i joined it and uh i went to one of
their events
yeah just one and it was a screening and
it was of paprika
right i was like okay it's a screening
and it's of a non ghibli movie okay
whoever is picking it must know they
have they have taste they they know
something outside of just
miyazaki i know i was like okay and and
i wanted to watch paprika because i
hadn't seen it yet
and so i went to it and the club wasn't
that big it was maybe
i'd say 40 people in this room yeah
which is quite small club for especially
sydney uni
and i was like okay these people all
seem to be excited about this movie
let's watch it
and this is the one thing i hate about
anime clubs and also this is the one
thing i hate about cinemas in the us
is that they love to [ __ ] commentate
on what's happening in the movie i
cannot stand that
i can't [ __ ] i can't stand especially
u.s cinemas
yes it's something about us cinemas
where it's like if there's like a big
epic right like say you go and watch
[ __ ] avengers or something yeah and
something massive happens or some you
know
whatever there's always like at least 10
or 20 people who are just like
yeah and they just go
off about like they give like they're
like [ __ ] rotten tomatoes
i feel like i'm 80 years old whenever
i'm like one of those screens because
i'm just like
quiet down i'm trying to enjoy the film
i'm like can you
shut the [ __ ] up we're trying to watch
the movie there's like special occasions
you know where it's kind of warranted
like watching uh
end game all right i get it you can
shout i watch pro man
ax insane the hype made it amazing you
the worst thing was
i uh one of my exes i went to the cinema
with never watched
uh a movie in the cinema before and i
was like all right cool
and then she was one of those people
didn't know that because how do you know
that
that's not like on a tinder buyer right
and then she like
shouted during the first five minutes
and i was like okay
in my head i'm thinking all right let's
let's not make this a reoccurring thing
and then like two minutes later shouts
again and i'm like please
please don't do that please i'm i'm
british
i can't do this i can't be seen with you
if you're making a commotion in public
yeah and that's how i realized that that
wasn't right for me that's why i like
japanese citizens man because like
it's no okay okay go ahead go ahead oh
no no i know how you feel about japanese
cinemas all right
but like for uh there's a part of it
that i like and there's a part of it
that i don't like the part that i like
about it is that people aren't [ __ ]
shouting their rotten tomatoes reviews
no one says anything no one says
anything i like that
yeah i like that because especially if
it's a movie that you need to immerse
yourself in like a [ __ ] paprika
for instance it's like i wanted to be
just quiet and
and i want to get into it yeah but the
uh the bad thing
is that i went to go see the connor
super movie right which is easily one of
the funniest anime movies i've ever seen
yeah and i but i felt really bad
laughing out loud because i was
literally the only person laughing out
loud in the cinema
and every time i was like
i don't think that was supposed to be
funny did anybody else find that funny
i've had similar experiences in uh thai
movies or
going to thai cinemas where i remember
watching your name entire cinemas and i
don't know if it's just a cultural
difference yeah but there would be
times when they were laughing and i
would be like what
what why why is this funny and then
they'd be a really funny joke and then
i'd be the only guy laughing
i'm like am i the [ __ ] here am i do i
just have a weird really weird sense of
humor i know
i feel so bad because i was like is is
anyone genuinely not finding this movie
funny like
am i the only one yeah i i hated it i've
been going to the cinema at least before
kovid like i was going like pretty much
every week
and like there's some of things they do
great like i know
i showed you guys this in the cinema
yeah that when you get buy popcorn on
the drink they give you this
this tray yeah and you're like oh that's
cool and then you realize
you can put it in the cup holder yeah
and it sticks so you have a whole tray
that's in the cup holder it's [ __ ]
genius yeah no i don't have to hold this
[ __ ] yeah yeah
i can just put it on you don't have to
put like [ __ ] greasy things yeah yeah
yeah
put your popcorn on your tray and the
person next you can you know have it
whatever
amazing right amazing and then uh the
thing that i hate
oh also yeah no noise the only time i've
ever seen the make noise in a japanese
cinema right i was watching the movie
and it was about a bomb that was
going to go off in one of the olympics
right yeah and it's this police officers
accused anyway they go to his house to
search his house
and they ask him do you have any guns
he's like yeah i have guns
and he shows his like under his mattress
and he has like a hundred guns
okay and the whole cinema goes whoa
every japanese first like whoa what's
good
and then also one really annoying thing
right when the movie ends
right the credits come all right see you
guys i'm off
japanese cinemas you cannot leave no
until the credits are over
yeah and some of these credits go on for
like 20 [ __ ] minutes
and i'm like the first few times i was
like you know what i'll respect the
culture
now i'm just like credits i'm going [ __ ]
you guys i'm not waiting for you can't
caveman brain activate again
i don't i don't care about the seven
people who did costume design i'm sorry
like i'm not sticking around for that
one and then like i'm the [ __ ] who
like in front of a hundred things like
all right see you guys
i'm just walking like i don't give a
[ __ ] i'm not waiting 30 minutes yeah i i
found that aspect cool because you know
obviously the people go to the cinemas
they they they're respecting they're
like okay i want to know who did and who
worked on this movie
but as you said i think the japanese
like film industry is aware that people
have to stick around to the chris that
are like
how do we like extend this as long as we
can it's like a youtuber trying to send
a video to 10 minutes like
how do we extend this credit to 10
minutes to get that mid-roll in
i don't know like i've i i used to be
the same where
i would think why the [ __ ] would anyone
stay when the credit's rolling i i i
give no i
i don't give a [ __ ] about this and i
remember i did it once for
a movie that just blew me away um i
think
um i can't remember the exact name
but i remember most recently i did it
after watching your name and silent
voice
and it's actually just a really nice
feeling just to
just to like absorb everything you just
watch and just sit there in silence i
don't know when
when sometimes i can live yeah when a
movie you like hits really deep
then like we're doing this again we're
doing this oh my god
but when when when a movie affects me
that way
there you go you got it you got the
money you got this just
then it's just nice just to absorb
everything you just watch instead of
just being like all right boys
i'm i'm off you know i'm off that that
was movie good i'm i'm i'm going
to be good no
no that's that's yeah no that's the one
thing i appreciate about some uh
film credits right like you know if it's
like i really enjoy watching you know
the toy story credits because they do
the you know the behind the scenes
bloopers
reels oh no like that shit's [ __ ]
cool but when it's
a black screen it's just white text
scrolling
which it often is which it often is and
then i'm just like
i mean you guys know we have to stick
around for the craze can you at least
make it
entertaining in some fashion and even
isn't it the worst
as well when the credits song is just
like i'm not digging this credits
at all and i have to [ __ ] sit here
and listen to the whole god damn
song i'm too lazy for that i just leave
and then i i watch the
after scene credit on youtube yeah it's
gonna be on yeah but you can use the
gaijin card right
uh yeah i mean no one really cares
sometimes when i do it the japanese be
like well we can do that
and then they'll get up too i noticed
follow the white man
wait wait wait wait no one's stopping
him
like i don't know he he just cheated the
system
i never thought you could do that
because when i do it i notice i'll get a
few lucks and then i'll be like two
people who stand up and go as well yeah
i'm like yeah join me it is it is
freedom so
it's like it's like the trust system
that japan runs on like buying alcohol
i'm slowly breaking it
i don't know i i've just the more i
don't know i say the older i get
i the more i i you know have less time
the more i just
don't appreciate [ __ ] the waste of my
time and i'm just like nope i'm not
waiting for your credits yeah
so speaking of gaijin car though have
you guys ever used the gaijin card
in like funny situations should we
explain what the gaijin card is
sure you should probably go for it go
for it i mean i'm sure everyone knows
what the gaijin card is right but
basically the gaijin card
is gaijin means foreigner yeah in
japanese but
the guys playing the gaijin card
basically means you get away with [ __ ]
that japanese people wouldn't be able to
get away with in japan
but they forgive you because you're
supposed to be like a mindless foreigner
i mean yeah
i i try not to actively like take
advantage of eggs i feel like it's not
fair for me to like use
you know being a foreigner yeah you know
because everyone goes through the same
struggles right life's hard enough
but i mean there's some stuff like
apparently you're not supposed to eat
and walk here right
yeah yeah i i do that i i don't like if
i if i have like 10 minutes to get to my
train and i haven't had breakfast yeah
i'm grabbing that sandwich and eating it
like
i don't throw my [ __ ] away i don't make
a mess so i'm like you know it's fine i
always wonder that that
then why is it that a lot of convenience
store food is so
perfectly packaged for on-the-go right i
know right and it's like
you can't eat it on the go though
onigiri just that that's that's
basically a rice sandwich
yeah that's that's meant to be eaten as
you're walking along but yeah
no you you know what you're watching no
one gives me looks or anything or
anything like that it's just uh
i i'm told i'm not supposed to do this
but [ __ ] i'm gonna do it anyway but the
stuff i wouldn't dare do i like playing
i like doing the reverse guiding card i
like playing the gaijin card and then
immediately after i've committed
the act just bust out the japanese just
like
psych reverse uno
can you give us an example of the
situation uh so an example of a
situation i'm trying to think
what would be i mean you know something
like that right like not allowed to eat
on the go or like not allowed to eat on
the train for example
where you know uh i would you know as
you said like sometimes i'm busy and
sometimes i gotta get something down
before i catch the train
so i would eat on the go and people
would kind of you know just
be like whatever um but then what i like
to do just to [ __ ] with people is
i i like to i finish the food
and then just just because i love seeing
people's reactions to this
i finish the food and then i pretend to
get in a phone call and i just
talk in japanese as loud as i can
just because seeing the confused phases
of japan
being like is he gaijin or is he not
guided
i don't even know anymore is my favorite
[ __ ] past time i've i've done
the exact same thing but just when i'm
in thailand yeah and you know when
you know when people gossip about you in
their native tongue you don't know
they don't know that you understand them
and you just want to flex on them to be
like
[ __ ] i know exactly what your mother
[ __ ] says
you better watch yourself [ __ ]
oh dude i've had so many experiences
like that especially when you're outside
of tokyo where
they're obviously not used to the
foreigners um
i was in the supermarket once uh with my
sister we were like really really young
maybe like i was maybe like nine or ten
years old oh wow um and we were just in
the
the the aisle that has all like the
snacks and stuff right because
japanese snacks are like the [ __ ]
best and we were just picking stuff out
and there was this kid probably around
the same age as me
who was just like staring at us from
like down the aisle
obviously because we looked foreigner
right yeah he'd obviously never seen a
foreign kid in his life
yeah so he was just staring and then his
other friend came up
and i could clearly hear that they were
like oh look at these [ __ ] foreigners
like
it was those nine-year-olds yeah
xenophobia fast yeah
legit they were like oh man look at
these foreigners that looks so weird
right like
you know there's something along that
yeah yeah yeah and i heard everything
and i'm just like oh you
[ __ ] prepare for my prepare for my
backhand
my nine-year-old backhand i've never
decked a nine-year-old before but today
could be the day
yeah you're pushing it i've never
close-lined anybody but man
you guys are just perfect distance so
just to [ __ ] with them i was like oh
sh my nine-year-old man was like i'll
show them
so i i sorry out loud to my sister
i said in japanese i said have you
finished selecting which one you want
and i think my sister quickly picked up
on it too because i think she overheard
it yeah so she was like all right i'll
play your game
and and back in japanese she was like
yeah i've almost finished um
and then she busted out this really like
specific japanese reference and from my
periphery
just i'd never seen like a nine-year-old
with like a pog champ face in my life
but it was just like they're like
what you would have thought these kids
would have seen like the face of god
like they were just like
oh my god what the [ __ ] is that and just
to [ __ ] with them even further
when we finish selecting our [ __ ] i
purposely went towards the kids
and as i passed by i busted out a
sumimasen
and that was just like the finishing
blow like that might as well i just
clotheslined them with my words right
there even a death note asked encounter
i [ __ ] kicked
the don't eat the [ __ ] out of that
that's so much more like passive than
what i think i used to do as a kid
joey slam dunks nine-year-old japanese
and language
swish i remember we used to go like
camping every year in france for like
three weeks dude i was
okay you're gonna think wow connor
you're a violent like [ __ ]
eleven-year-old
okay i i [ __ ] spent all my time in
the arcades
i remember this one time this kid had
been like taunting me
yeah like his french kid i [ __ ] hated
him you've been taunting me for like
days
and i'm playing metal slug right and you
know how you put like two credits in
like you press the credit button yeah
yeah it's like oh cause i'm playing and
i put another one in for me when i die
this [ __ ] this 11 year old [ __ ] who
comes along
presses the start credit button and then
walks away
and then i immediately just turn around
just [ __ ] smack him in the face
i got in so much trouble i had like an
angry french dad shouting at me at like
i'm like 11 right
and i'm like this is his dad [ __ ]
shouting at me because this kid's crying
yeah
i'm like i'm gonna finish my game
and then i'll deal with this my dad had
such a [ __ ] go at me
you were that xbox kid when yeah i was
definitely like
a pen top right i was like i was such an
angry kid i have no idea why but i'm
glad though because like now i just like
just can't even get angry to be fair i'd
be pretty pissed off too if something
random [ __ ] kid came up to me did
that yeah when you're like 11 right this
is also my parents didn't give me much
money yeah and i would only i would
always use it on the games right so to
me
this kid had just taken like the only
money i was getting yeah like
that whole trip and i was like oh no oh
we all know like 20 11 year old like
three
like like three like two or like three
credits or the whole slug is like the
equivalent to your mom's credit card
yeah i [ __ ] love medals like man that
kid took my credit
no like i can totally understand why you
got angry i just thought man there's
this
there's a few steps between between
taking someone's credit and smacking
someone in this package
this kid had been giving me [ __ ] because
like a campsite he'd been giving me [ __ ]
for days and i'm just like i'm done dude
i'm done
i'm fuming i just straight up punched it
i got so much [ __ ] for that and then
like two days later the same kid who i
punched had a black eye
he came he came while i was on my other
[ __ ] game just pulls out the plug
and i was like and i [ __ ] chased him
but he ran off did you oh i was
i was just giving him another i was
gonna [ __ ] kill him
[ __ ] pulled out the plug whilst
i was mid metal slug i'm sorry
wow yeah i don't even remember this is
gonna be a weird question but when was
the first time you ever punched someone
bro i got in so many fights was that was
that the first time you ever punched
someone
did you not fight with like oh wait do
you only have a sister i only had a
sister oh dude i have three brothers
dude if i punch my sister i would my my
dad would
my dad used to say this one threat it's
like a legit threat
right where like if i did anything like
bad in public he just like grabbed my
ear and just whispered being like i
brought you into this world i can easily
take you out
my dad won't remember that but i
specific like it's an eight-year-old
that's like
i'm sorry for that 101. me and my
brothers so we had three brothers right
yeah so it was wrestlemania like oh yeah
we must have fought i must have been in
this fight like three days of the week
right right um was it actually fist
fights or was it like oh yeah it got to
the point we would like actually start
like full on punching each other jesus
yeah yeah we hated each other i love him
now i love you guys but
then it was like [ __ ] because oh god
there's so many fights but yeah
my dad had this thing we called it like
he's probably gonna kill me if i say
this but he had this thing called the
murder stare
and like you know when you started
[ __ ] up and he would look at you and
you're like
he's like bro you're one step away from
like losing everything
right now it was the look where you he
was like don't do it don't do one more
thing
i'll end you love you dad by the way
because i was an only child so i i had
never had to grow up with any siblings
never had to share anything
um but yeah that was i had a fairly
uneventful childhood because of that i
think in 2020 we call that privilege
i got bullied so much in school so i
just started just [ __ ] punching
everyone back
i guess yeah if you get bullied at
school you probably have like a lot of
people yeah i mean after i started
punching
back and you know actually getting
fights people just left me alone because
they knew if
they would go for someone else who
wouldn't fight back yeah exactly should
i just challenge them to a chess game
i should have man that would have
definitely worked against kids you
should have challenged them to a chess
game and then the moment you when you
just punch them in the face
it's like double down on it
so bad i don't know what stories i could
tell if you want any
i mean i'm just trying to think like
when was the i did you ever punch anyone
in school
like full-on punch someone yeah i have
um
what reason uh because this kid it's
always dumb as [ __ ] in the sky
yeah it's because this kid in my high
school was giving me [ __ ] like he was he
was the bully about you
but the thing is he was that one bully
that you know how some bullies are kind
of like
popular with the kids that they don't
bully yeah this kid
because he bullied everybody like every
single person everybody [ __ ] hated
this kid
and of course eventually he made the
rounds and the next target was me for
whatever reason
but and obviously going to a high school
where it's a 99 percent white boys and
i'm the only one with a non-white
bloodline of course
yeah he's going for the low hanging
fruit yeah yeah yeah so
he would you know say all these like
horribly racial slurs
at me and stuff and uh and just one day
he got
he was just really and i didn't mind the
racial slurs it's it's when he got
up to my face i hate it i hate that so
much there's a difference between a
bully
shouting across the playground yeah at
you yeah i don't mind that stuff yeah it
was just fine right because that shit's
easy
but respect my personal space yeah right
the moment you cross
into my personal space that's when the
hands come out yeah
and i i never punched anyone in my life
up until that point yeah and i was like
okay there's only one way that this kid
is going to stop
and he's like and in my head i was like
doing a kaiji episode where i'm like if
i punch him i'm either going to die
or or i'm going to come out of this
alive
joey's like death noting every action
bad this is like the total opposite the
way i used to think about it i was like
just just punch and figure it out
oh no no no i was always the person who
was like okay what's gonna happen if i
go
down this route it was like a visual
novel right it's like punch or not punch
and it's like
i don't know i don't want to get the
band i want to get the bad end right
so i was like oh so i was like there's a
very good possibility that if i punch
i'm going to just like
batter just and i was like but
this kid was just relentlessly just like
shouting in my face and just you know
like and then the moment he started like
pushing me around as well that's when
that's when i think i just snapped yeah
yeah yeah yeah way all back and just
knock this kid in the chat like i
brought the [ __ ] bucky move on
knocked him in the chin and he fell down
on the ground and
he just kind of walked off and then
nobody in my ear [ __ ] with me
that's good that years and that's like
okay oh this all right that was the good
end that was good
like when you know i'd never recommend
like fighting back because it can
normally like it can go like two ways
right
one you can get your kick
like spit on each other in school and it
was that was the stuff that bothered me
the most like yeah you can call me [ __ ]
don't spit on me what the [ __ ]
yeah i hated high school did you guys
have this i don't know if this is only
an australian high school thing but
the last year of the 12th grade like
literally the day before graduation
i forgot what it was called i think it
was called like year 12 free day
where basically the 12th graders for the
last day of high school
they can just run around the school and
do whatever the [ __ ] they want i think
we had something similar in our school
yeah what you guys didn't have but like
our school took that free day literally
where some [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] would
happen like we
we somehow uh uh we you know the the
it started off quite innocently like
yeah you know putting lube all over the
stair rails and stuff like that and
another one was going into one of the
teachers offices and filling his entire
cup
uh entire floor with cups full of water
so that he couldn't like go into the
into his thing like that
and then it got too far when uh
one of i think was like a group of boys
they got one of the
teachers cars and i don't know how the
[ __ ] they did it
i think it was driving a mini so it was
like relatively small car
and they somehow put the car on top of
one of the school buildings
like on the roof and i mean that's too
far but
that just sounds impressive honestly the
engineering what are the
logistics behind this you know this
kid's going forward
i wasn't there to witness it but imagine
just walking to school and you're
walking
you know along the school uh like wall
yeah and you just look up and there's
just a car
sitting there i'm just like oh how did
that get there
like the news or some [ __ ] no no no no
this is like this is quite
frequent that sounds like a scene from
some american what do you mean
this sounds like a scene from some
american high school movie that you
watch and you're like oh this is so
[ __ ] stupid this one never happened
i don't know i don't know if my high
school still does it but that's
newsworthy in the uk i think
that would be yeah of course [ __ ]
hell no even the even the girls schools
would go crazy like that as well just
what the [ __ ]
because it was you know it was the last
last day of high school right yeah it's
like
do whatever the [ __ ] you want while you
can because after this day
you have adult responsibility so it's
like just it's it's you know
it's the miley cyrus effect right it's
like just get all that [ __ ] out of the
way
once the contract has ended and you're
good to go right well like i said he
must have learned some good skills from
being able to [ __ ] get a mini on a
school roof
yeah how would you do that even if it
wasn't like a multi-story
building it was like it was like a
demountable so it was just like just
getting it up but still
still there's like eight of them
coordinate this lift
like i had nothing to go wrong i wasn't
i wasn't there to witness it but it was
awesome just
staring across the school grounds and
just seeing a [ __ ] mini
on top of it yeah that was crazy how do
you convince kids to join yeah so we're
gonna go lift the teacher's mini yeah
like i need like five boys who's in this
like all right i'll [ __ ] do it yeah
speaking of like high school why is
there so many high school anime you know
what i mean
wow that transition gone i was i was
just like mad [ __ ] he's on it
i'm [ __ ] on it that far what's the
deal with high school
what's the deal with high school anime
no because that sounds crazier than any
[ __ ] high school anime
i've ever heard of or [ __ ] seen some
crazy high school anime out there
like it's either one or it's either one
of two ways it's either like the most
people
did you guys have like school festivals
in your high school like how they have
in japan i think that's only a japanese
high school thing isn't it bro in japan
they make a school look so fun and
british school is the most depressing
[ __ ] oh no i like to do anything you
guys are here telling your high school
stories i don't remember it
[ __ ] i remember [ __ ] all from my high
school all i remember is bad
bad things see people always say that i
actually had a i think i'm like the one
percent that actually had a good time in
high school
i think i had a um i think i had a good
i liked my friend group a lot yeah but i
had those four of us we were all really
close but yeah
stuff that happened in school was just
always awful like what
i don't know i got so much i got in so
many fights as a kid oh yeah i mean i
guess you yeah yeah yeah
like there was one time as well this is
one story i remember and this like drove
my blood like through the roof dude
yeah so there's a day in the uk i don't
know if you do this in australia where
like the kids who are coming into high
school get like two days
before the like in like june before
september starts yeah where they get to
just come and see the school
yeah my little brother was coming up
right oh like an orientation yeah
yeah so i was like showing my little
brother around and one of the the guys
just
the bullies just comes up to me whilst
i'm talking to my little brother
just slaps me in the face what just
slaps me in the face
and i this is already i'd already been
in like multiple fights at this point
right
um and me and i i get slapped and i'm
like all right it's go time
are you
literally just slaps me and then i'm
like wait there
because i was like thinking like i got
to show my little brother i'm not a
[ __ ]
right yeah he's my little brother he
looks up to me right like i got to show
her that like i'm not a [ __ ]
right because if you see me get slapped
i'm like oh sorry sorry he's gonna think
wow
my big brother's kind of a wimp what's
up with that
this just sounds almost sounds like a
[ __ ] in-betweeners episode it is
because then it turned into a [ __ ]
tournament arc where then all his
friends the next day were like oh well
we want to turn now
jesus christ there's one time and this
is probably the one where i felt most
bad
is that this guy came up to me he's like
kind of chubby
what are you doing what are you doing
man right what's up with this
he pushes me once and i was like all
right fine
i grab his head and just [ __ ] knee
him
and bear in mind okay i do not do not
condone violence
in any sense but but i lost it i was
such an angry 13 year old because i was
getting bullied since like you were 13
when you did this yeah
what the [ __ ] so you weren't even in
high school you're like middle school
maybe like no i'm like 13 like 15 14
maybe maybe 50 yeah still
15 yeah and this guy didn't i've never
had a problem with this guy i didn't
realize why he was doing this to me but
i think i
pissed off one of his friends and then
he you know trying to act big i don't
think he actually wanted the fight he
was just pushing me around
but i was like [ __ ] it anyway so i did
that and he just dropped and i was like
oh no
oh no i'm going to be in there i'm going
to be in a lot of trouble
i don't even think i did it that hard i
just thought i saw it in a movie once it
looked really [ __ ] cool
i saw bruce lee do it once i could do it
sir who gets hurt by getting kneed in
the face
so he pushed me and then i think he was
going think i was going to arrow for a
push and i just went like douche
and then he just like dropped for like
five seconds and i was like oh [ __ ] are
you okay
and he was like yeah yeah i'm fine and i
think he was so embarrassed that he
didn't tell anyone right
and then he came in the next day two
black eyes
wait how did you get two black how wide
is your knee
so we came in with two black eyes didn't
tell anyone but all my friends knew what
happened
no one said anything it was like that
one week where i had like three fights
right no one did anything for me the
rest of my school life it was great
everyone everyone was nice to me
you had more fights in that one week
than i think i have my entire life i
think i had more fights in that one week
than anything this is like fight club
because it might work
in my school it was it wasn't about like
getting into fights it was about
who did you know like if you're cool
with x person if you call it that person
yeah yeah people don't [ __ ] with you
i don't know if it's because it's like a
small town thing like my and like the
uh it was such a small town thing yeah
like the teachers often like forgave the
shitty behavior because
more often than not all the teachers
were friends with the kids parents right
so
yeah it was kind of a thing of like oh
don't do it again don't do it again
stop like you need someone in the face
every single time it was like don't do
it again don't do it again
you know it wasn't like a proper
punishment right now i mean you know
it's it is what it is right i don't
really care now i've i dealt with it
myself did you go to a boys school
no oh okay so maybe that's the aspect of
a ride because i feel that
boys will be more willing to get into
fights if it's a co-ed school because
they're trying to like impress
the girls i never wanted to i just
wanted to play my game to be like yeah
but it just
there was like one guy who would like he
he didn't want to fight me he didn't
want to fight me because he i think he
knew that he'd get hurt
so he would just oh like i said he would
spit on me and anytime i try to like
fight him he'd just run away
so what can i do right it's like that
one [ __ ] who like kites amazingly
come to me
his torn game's like on point yeah yeah
yeah he just kites you and he's just
kidding me
then he would run to an area with
teachers right and i can't [ __ ] like
punch him
if any 13 year old 14 kids don't fight
it's not a good solution
i mean i i was just lucky that i was
freakishly strong for a 12 or 13 year
old as well that helped a lot
yeah um i don't know because for me i've
always gone through life being like
okay physical physical like interaction
is always like my last choice
yeah yeah yeah i have that now but as a
kid i felt like it was my only
you weren't the hard way yeah i mean i'm
i'm glad that i was angry as a kid
because now i have like
zero anger at all right i never get
angry about [ __ ] now i'm so glad that i
just got that [ __ ] out
you know i don't know if that's how
anger works i don't know if this is
science
i'm not sure about that it's not but i
feel like because i've dealt with so
much anger
in in my past right i've been able to
like really like
i don't know it's like you feel it's
like you feel
i get like mildly frustrated at things
like any good british person would but
i never get angry at things mildly
frustrated it's just
the british that's just the default
british emotion yeah you know
anything can mildly frustrate you and
and that's just that's just the way
we've just grown up right yeah
i'll be angry about [ __ ] now but i'll be
like angry you know like
i play it up because i like just
shouting but yeah but
god is like the chillest man on earth
like gone is impossible to get mad
i've never actually seen you mad well i
mean that's the whole monk thing right
yeah yeah do you want to talk about it
oh
that was am i watching an anime right
now damn son what are we talking about
today joey
we're talking about two particular
series that bookwork
is releasing on their website uh i don't
know if you've heard of a conor i'm sure
uh gone you've heard of it but there is
two series there's one
called uh tempu which is about a
temple surprise surprise with a monk
with a monk
with a monk perfect segue into the next
part of the show
but also the other one is uh
which i don't know what the english
title is why the hell are you here
teacher that's
it i've seen episode one of this show my
goodness gracious that is not christian
but yeah i'm so glad i can read it on
bookwalker in the comfort of my home
yes because on bookwalker the manga is
completely uncensored you get
full nips and everything if you've ever
thought about getting with your teacher
because that's
that's basically the show okay that's
basically that's basically the manga i
need no more
but you might need more because the
other manga that they have is tempuru
which uh
is illustrated by the same guy no sorry
yeah illustrated by the same guy who did
grand blue you know grand blue i do know
i do yeah so illustrated by the
completely same guy just different
writer but essentially as the name
suggests it's about this kid
who has these really dirty thoughts but
he wants to be a good christian so he
basically goes to a temple to get rid of
his
horny on mean christian thoughts but the
problem is that he
becomes a monk at a temple that is full
of hot women
that doesn't sound very monkey today
did that happen to you mom i want to be
a monk i swear
yeah this was the real reason that i
became the market hoping for that
scenario that sounds pretty good yeah
yeah and but like the thing is
because it's illustrated by the same guy
the grand blue the type of comedy is
exactly the same as ground blue so if
you love the like
really vulgar visual comedy that really
made grand blue funny like tempura is
exactly the same way and the added bonus
is that
it's way more hot girls in temperature
than ground blue so guys i'm i'm getting
some breaking news from book walker here
uh both
tempuru and why the hell are you here
teacher are exclusive to book walker
until august 13th
you can read half of volume one of both
titles
for free free gentlemen free or
buy them for 50 off
can we keep that audrey yes and lastly
volume 2 of why the hell are you here
teacher comes with a book walker
exclusive
colored booklet damn and in brackets
they've said here extra edgy gentlemen
extra itchy i don't know what that means
i don't know if my penis can handle that
how can they get extra edgy
what's what's the extraness in the
etching
it's that the skin is colored this time
it's not just black and white
if that sounds remotely interesting to
you
you can check it out in the link below
thank you to bookwork for sponsoring
today's video
if you want more sponsor reads like that
please actually go and go check out
these books they are actually amazing
and and we love doing these silly ad
reads and if
you like it please go support them show
them that these ad reads work
thank you back to the video so yeah it's
a little known
secret or it's literally in fact that
i've i've been a monk
in my life but i've not just been a monk
once right just saying that is so cool
to me this is just part of buddhist
culture so in buddhist culture
um normally when you want to give your
family like good karma
everyone in my family has been a monk
like twice in their life
once when they're a teenager and once
when they're like
an adult so you you you become a monk
like
once when you're when you're like a
teenager we call that being
um and then there's you become like a
full monk when you
become an adult and that's when you kind
of hit like your early 20s
okay okay so yeah so normally a lot of
people just do it like for like one or
two days
because we believe that it's good karma
yeah um i remember when i was about
12 or 13 i i was a monk for two weeks
and then afterwards when i was about 22
23 i was a monk for a full month jeez
yeah yeah because i cuz i because you
told me stories about how you were a
monk for an entire
month but i never knew that you did it
twice oh yeah yeah i mean i mean to me
it's just
not part of like being a buddhist and
you know trying to get i was trying
i was that good little asian kid i was
trying to give like my family good karma
and everything but
i honestly i honestly like wrapped the
experience because it was
i'm not i'm not joking when it was
literally the life-changing experience
for me like well that was it
that was me before being a monk and then
there's me after being a monk
because normally people just do it just
to you know
uh just to impress their family and just
give give their family good karma
but i i told my mom if i'm gonna do it
i'm gonna go
all the way like yeah yeah like there's
there's some temples that you go to
that don't take it as seriously and then
i i went to a [ __ ] hardcore temple
where you know we didn't have any
technology
yeah uh we had to okay so here was my
daily schedule
okay so i would have to wake up at
around 4am
that already sounds like torture that
already sounds like
like have have to be ready have to be
completely ready by five
okay and we didn't have any beds we had
a concrete floor
and one little pillow to sleep on oh my
god and we had like the thinnest blanket
in the world which wasn't so bad because
it's thailand but
when sometimes when you're sleeping in
the middle of the forest because there
would be times when we just go out to a
temple in the middle of the forest
it can get [ __ ] cold the temperature
drops to about
two or three degrees sometimes and and
like you you just have this like tiny
little blanket on a concrete floor
to keep you warm right so we'd have to
wake up at four get ready by five
and then we'd just be like meditating
and praying for a good two three hours
every day and then afterwards we would
basically
go out barefoot go to like whatever
village or
whatever area around the temple um and
people would just donate
donate the food to we would have these
we would carry like these little baskets
um on our necks
and people would come over and they
would you know donate food or whatever
they want to donate because we believe
that if you give to a monk that's good
karma as well yeah yeah
so the food that we got donated that's
what we would eat
so we we would walk around for a few
hours for the entire day
yeah for the inside or was it like just
like enough or
i mean you you get what you're given
right
you had no choice about what you could
eat you could eat basically what you
were given did you ever get anything
like super nasty
no i mean it's it's i guess in in the
mindset you're not like picky you're
like oh really a snickers
really no because
the whole point of being a monk is that
you don't okay you don't care like you
you
you eat to survive i guess if you're
caring about that that's like no that's
that's defeating the point of being a
monk so you you get what you're given
and you
you live the simplest life you can
possibly live and you basically eat to
survive
and you get one meal a day and you gotta
you gotta be okay with whatever you get
given so we would
eat at around 11 to 12 o'clock and that
would be our first
and only meal a day it was it was easier
when you're a kidman because kid amongst
you get two meals
a day okay yeah but when you're an adult
yeah when you're an adult when you're
more
grown up burning through more calories
nope
you got to survive on one meal a day and
afterwards you could there was no
cheating so after that you couldn't have
any milk
or any like liquids that had calories
you could only have water water
or some kinds of fruit juices and and
that was it
and yeah it was it was very
i i i don't know really how to describe
the experience because imagine if you
just take
every every distraction out of your life
and you just live the simplest life
possible you don't need to enjoy
your food you know you you get you don't
really get
the pleasures in life but at the same
time you just kind of
you're okay with everything because you
have to be okay with everything
and i remember for the first
week of being a monk it's [ __ ] hard
it is so [ __ ] hard to reprogram your
brain
to not only be like okay how do i
distract myself with my phone how do i
not check twitter how do i not watch
youtube videos how do i just
be okay with my own thoughts and just
and and it's so hard because your brain
nowadays your brain constantly
constantly looking forward to something
yeah
it constantly needs something to
distract itself um
and the first week i was just you're
kind of like a drug addict right
i'm sorry i should tweet give me a tweet
i'm i'm sitting there trying to meditate
and my mind's just going out a million
miles an hour
yeah i haven't watched tv in in a week i
haven't seen a screen in a week it's
it's very very difficult but the more
time you do it the more you kind of your
you realize that oh this is this this is
all
these are all just distractions like you
can be completely okay with just
yourself
and your own thoughts and just doing the
simplest things
and life activities and then when
i got to that point i kind of just had
time to just reflect
on my entire life because what else what
else what else are you gonna [ __ ] do
when you have nothing to do
but literally think back about
everything
every decision that you've made in your
life and the way your mind works
you know you know when you're sometimes
you're like lying in bed at 11 a.m and
your
brain reminds you about shitty thing
about that embarrassing thing you did
when you were 12 or maybe like
that time when you punched a [ __ ] kid
in front i'm like oh my god i got him
good
so just just imagine your entire day
just being
that just being like uh i wonder if i'd
made the right choice at this point in
my life and then
what happened to me was that i kind of
just reflected on
every every little decision that kind of
that kind of led me up to this point in
my life and what it made me
what it forced me to do was really think
huh am i
really happy about where i am now like
what's what's my life going to be like
out when
when i when this monkey ends and
i was at a really bad point in my life
before i became a monk which is kind of
why i've really wanted to
commit to the facts of being
like if if i was going to be a monk i'm
going to go all the way
get the full detox yeah get the full
detox you know because i've seen some
temples you you walk in and they have
like a flat like a 50 inch flat screen
and i'm like this is the monk channel
only
we only have the mung channel this
doesn't seem very monkey to me
i don't know about that except paypal
you turn the tv on it's like a live
stream of like a different temple and
then like
praying exactly nice nice content
so so it forced me to just reflect on my
entire life and it forced me to really
think about what i wanted to do
after my monkey had ended so it was
truly
a i don't want to say [ __ ] it was a
spiritual journey and i really just
discovered i mean i thought in this
instance you can because it but it
only
because people have talked to me about
how they have you know how they've had
similar experiences when they just
shut off social media and everything
like that yeah and i'm just like
you know no you're already yeah bruh
bruh
you don't even know get on my level yeah
get on my level bro
like you didn't have any board games you
didn't have any cards to just
play around or all you just had was just
yourself and
and it's just it i can't really convey
how alien that is because it it was
alien for me as well it was a part of me
that just a vision
like you know because as you said the
only thing you had was just yourself and
your mind right yeah yeah and
all i could imagine was just monk gone
just sitting there and just thinking up
a funny jokes
i'm gonna roast these noobs when i get
back good roast oh no no no
that that's that totally happened as
well that's when i was a monk that's
when
i uh thought about hmm there's a series
i'm going to make called anime in
minutes
are you serious i'm totally serious
i'm totally serious that that came to me
when i i remember the exact moment
because i was i was just walking around
um walking around one of the thai
villages and
it just it just it just [ __ ] came to
me because i i thought i remember
last uh not last week but a few weeks
ago i talked about being zen
on the [ __ ] toilet in the shower yeah
yeah so that was that's kind of like
i i kind of sometimes when i'm just
walking and i'm just
you know just zoning out sometimes i've
reached this
point when a lot of ideas just come to
me and it came to me when
i was a monk as well and i had i got a
lot of video ideas
and a lot of a lot of ideas when i was a
monk
sensei yeah which which which it was it
was
these ideas when i was a monk that have
developed to me like to my comeback on
youtube
where i figured out okay if i'm going to
come back on youtube how i was i was
going to come back on youtube yeah
but yeah this has been a very closely
guarded secret because
you want there are some there are some
youtube some very old youtube clips
where i'm just wearing i'm just wearing
a beanie and nobody knows why i'm just
wearing a beanie
and it was because it just i had just
finished my monkey and i was just
completely bold
yeah what if they just like took it in a
really dark direction it's like oh no
the cancer treatment yeah yeah how do
you like sign up to be a monk do you
just
is it like a facebook group you're like
i wanna i wanna be a mother you know
like how do you
[ __ ]
yeah i mean you just turn up to whatever
temple you you want to
do and they they're like okay you go to
the head monk and you request
to be a monk and they ask okay before
you become a monk you need to make sure
you have you have no outstanding debts
yeah you basically you've got to give up
all material connections to the world
before you can commit to becoming a monk
and you'll have like this interview
where you're like okay if you're gonna
become a monk you gotta make sure
yeah do this do this do this you know
you know what would be a really cool
idea for
this channel if like us 3 somehow went
to like a temple here
and just like experienced it for like a
single day wow
already on that [ __ ] hey if you guys
would like to see that
monk episode monk episode like god could
be like head monk of trash case it's
just [ __ ] like we have to shave our
heads you do realize that jerry
[ __ ] i just know i can do it all over
again i can commit to that
i know you caught your hair
but like i don't really talk about it
but now that now that i am i do
like highly recommend that kind of
experience or just
or just do it doing that kind of
experience because you don't notice
how like how distracting life is like
just
like you don't you don't realize that as
soon as you wake up you got things to
occupy your mind yeah
you got your job or you got you know you
wait you
the first thing you do is you check
twitter you open arc nights
and you don't you don't know how crazy
your mind can be sometimes so you
literally remove
every distraction every commitment that
you need to do from your daily life and
you just have
you just have nothing because it's just
it's just a void right
you're just giving your life a void and
because you give your life a void
it [ __ ] changes you i i don't know i
don't i don't know how else i know
i totally get that like back when i was
still doing youtube stuff
um i would i went on this like camping
trip with a few of my friends
and we went to this area that had
absolutely no reception whatsoever oh
whales
yeah we went all the way to wales no we
were just in the [ __ ] middle of
nowhere in australia with no reception
and we would just went camping and
because there's no reception
i couldn't check anything right like i
couldn't like i couldn't even like
message you
this is like a light version yeah it's
basically just like a dieting
yeah a diet version of it but i i kind
of had
like a similar experience to that but
only like for that one day and i
remember
the first couple of hours i [ __ ]
hated it because yeah
yeah i was getting those you know like
drug addicts like i need i need to know
who liked my tweet
but after a while like when it hit
around midday i
i eventually was like you know what this
is actually really nice like yeah
the world is beautiful that's why i love
going to the cinema like it's a
no one can like be like why don't you
answer your phone like yeah in every
other situation like oh you should have
answered
still in the cinema for some reason i
was like understandable have a nice day
you ignored my text for three hours
understandable it's just like a void
right it's great like i love it you just
literally ignore the world for like
three hours and just have fun yeah
and that's why it frustrates me when the
void gets pulled back to reality when
someone in the back is just [ __ ]
shouting yeah yeah just being like oh
yeah i forgot this reality
oh yeah because especially now i think i
don't know the internet's i feel like
has reprogrammed my brain
yeah i don't remember i don't know if i
just have adhd
because i didn't always felt like i was
this easily distracted it's like
subconsciously building patterns in your
head though like because
you you've trained your brain to check
twitter
yeah and so you'll you you'll have that
moment and i'm sure you've all had it
where you're like you opened twitter you
closed twitter and you opened twitter
again and you're like why did i open
twitter again yeah like i didn't want to
open like i literally just refreshed my
feet two seconds ago i
i didn't want to do this i just didn't
you check twitter on your computer
and you realize there's nothing nothing
you checked it and then you immediately
check it on your phone why am i doing
this i wasted time
it's the same concept just going to the
fridge seeing nothing there closing it
sitting back on the couch and then five
minutes later going to the fridge
it's like it's like food's gonna
magically appear in the freezer right
yeah so i i mean it was it was
it was an awesome experience for me i
like i don't you know if
if that's not something that's if not
that's it's a little bit it's not an
experience for everyone
the question is though would you do it
again um i
would do it again possibly maybe not to
this extreme because i feel like i'm in
a lot better place in my life i'm a lot
more privileged now
no i mean like like not not just not
just that but like mentally yeah i'm in
a lot better place in my life as well
um so i don't feel i would need to go to
that extreme again but
would i want an experience where i just
kind of just remove myself from the
world and just give myself
it's like a short detox yeah yeah yeah
that's that's it's like a detox from the
mind yeah this is how i feel it
and i i highly recommend people doing
that it sounds really cheesy because
people will always think of that leo
some some crazy californian gap y'all
like going on a gap yeah i took a gap
year to thailand became a mom
exactly that right i was just like shut
up dude
you probably went to the club every
night like shut up yeah so that's why i
don't really
i don't really like to talk about it
because whenever whenever you say yeah
it's unpretentious it sounds pretentious
people give you that look to be like
why because it makes it sound like you
it was like a vacation for you whereas
it was probably someone's life right
yeah yeah yeah that's why it sounds
or maybe or maybe it sounds like it
because maybe some people think you just
went through it just to brag about it
like later on yeah yeah exactly
the fact that you've you you don't
really talk about this
i never talk about this i remember i i
dragged you i dragged that conversation
out of you
we were like really drunk it's in
singapore like three
years ago i think i just drunkly
offhanded mentioned
so were you like were you ever angry
before you were a monk because i swear
i've never seen you angry what's up with
that gun
i mean i i i've been angry before you
get mildly frustrated you don't get
even when you're angry i'm like dude you
i don't know if you're angry angry
no like like being a monk just taught me
how to deal with it think
about the whole process basically
process everything right because
when when you just kind of empty your
mind you part part of
part of the uh commitment we try to make
is that we try to
learn how we process our way of thinking
and you gotta like
you gotta kind of it's i okay so the way
i see it
it's kind of like a logic tree right and
and and
and this is what happened to me when i
was a monk where i'd feel certain
emotions and you'd have to like
logically think
be like why am i feeling this why am i
feeling this how did this come
and then you kind of learn the roots of
basically all your emotions and just
anger and then
through that i just on the fly i learned
how to deal with my anger and just and
just i would find another route to be
like okay
before i get angry maybe i could go
maybe i could try dealing
with another way which is why i rarely
get angry
um and i always you know some people get
angry very easily
um but for me it's not that i don't get
angry is that i just
have different ways of dealing about it
than of course than shouting or [ __ ]
death i just love
shouting man okay i don't punch anyone
anymore that's old
old connor's gone new connor he just
wears cosplays and shouts loudly yeah
yeah yeah i love shouting i love like
when i shout out
i [ __ ] love shouting
i don't know why shouting is so fun like
so do you like purposely shout to just
get like
that frustration now before it turns
into legit anger or
sometimes if i'm like real angry some
days or i wake up and i'm upset i'll
just go in the mirror
and i'll be like come on
i only hear i only see that in like
movies right like
that [ __ ] i wouldn't be i wouldn't be
surprised if you're the kind of person
who just like punches their pillow
frustration out but i just imagined you
in the [ __ ] morning every every
morning
okay like in the mirror god you got you
got this kind of
you got it okay okay you you [ __ ] got
it okay
some days actually actually okay some
days you wake up right you'll feel like
man i feel kind of
kind of shitty today man like i don't
know why man i'm kind of worthless right
i get in front of that mirror i'm like
you got this
okay my neighbors probably hate me [ __ ]
it i'm hyped i'm ready for the day
that that energy rushes through you i
feel like i feel like
i feel like i i feel like a 10
immediately it's so monkey bro
i love it oh my goodness i'm feeling
intense straight away the start of my
day
uh quest question to you guys how do you
guys hype yourself up before recording
session
for your videos because there's gonna be
a time
okay no okay okay this is the thing that
shane i think this is because you're
you've
you've just recently started doing it a
lot right yeah because i remember when i
first started filming my face a lot
i [ __ ] dreaded doing it oh yeah i did
everything to avoid it i would be like i
would shave
like three times just to make sure it
was perfect in my head but rece but
really what i was doing was delaying it
yeah
yeah yeah like oh my god maybe i need to
go get the groceries actually i should
do
laundry action oh it's too late to focus
yeah oh
i can't recall because i was too busy
renovating my house yeah yeah but now
now i just [ __ ] turn it on and do it
i don't i already think about it yeah i
don't really
i don't really hype myself i have a
coffee maybe a red bull if i need it but
that's about it yeah caffeine helps
definitely but i don't i don't really
have like a do it phase you know
in the morning if you're feeling down
man try it next time okay
next time you feel sad right and you
wake up because it happens sometimes man
you just feel shitty
just try it you'll feel like an idiot at
first but then you'll be like
nice dude aki's going to clown on me i
was about to say sydney's going to be
like
no one lives with me so it's like yeah
okay you can do it by yourself but it's
just like
city's like god what are you doing who
are you saying come
[Laughter]
i realized i'm slowly forming a profile
for me of just like a complete monkey on
this part
yeah i think i think the only like
hyping up i do
maybe you know sometimes if if because
i'm not
going to even think about recording a
video if i'm already not in that state
right
yeah i've realized just don't film if
you don't yeah yeah so like before i
used to
i used to you know have to be like okay
i have to [ __ ] record something
yeah and then i would turn the camera on
and immediately you hear the moment you
hit that record button you're just like
[ __ ] man yeah you're like ugh i hate my
life right
but i didn't have a choice because i was
uploading you know every two days or so
yeah yeah yeah yeah but with my current
schedule now i have a little bit
more levity in that so i definitely
i just know if i wake up in the morning
and today's the day where i can just get
something out
because fr if i feel good already from
the morning then i'm like all right
it's it's time to get that bread game is
like let's let's [ __ ] record like
three
three videos just get that [ __ ] while
the [ __ ] hype train is right yeah
sometimes playing hype music will get me
in the zone oh yeah
nice funk
dude like power of music man like that
that [ __ ] can easily hide
what do you like how do you know what
music to pick how do you know what music
to pick
i i i let youtube decide for me
do i go with slow beat or fast beats
that's song happy
your youtube search history for music is
just like an ai trying to understand
what the emotions are this is how my
music tastes works and how i find songs
i like one song and then i'll just
keep letting youtube suggest me songs
and i'll keep building i never like
actively look out for songs i just let
it suggest this is like youtube and
spotify recommendations were built for
people like you
dude they're amazing man it's really
[ __ ] good though
i i used to i was die-hard spotify for
like six years maybe longer
and then i just tried youtube music once
because i had it with premium yeah and i
was like holy [ __ ] i think i
think i like this more oh dude but i've
discovered so
much good music through spotify
recommended i think
yeah youtube you find a lot because they
have a lot of there's a lot of songs
that
aren't official that you'll get on
youtube music that are like remixes that
yeah will never be on spotify because
they wouldn't
oh i don't really give a [ __ ] about the
remix there's so many good ones there's
like one where it's like uh
the sort of chino salameh mixed with
like that 90s song by like diana ross or
something
that [ __ ] claps man i'll i'll i'll send
you a link there's always the good anime
remakes
there's so many good anime releases on
youtube that you're not allowed on
spotify
right yeah and like because sometimes i
want to listen to like daft punk but i
also want to have
you know that anime remix yeah so i can
do that on youtube
hell yeah dude i've recently kind of
gone into the rabbit hole of
the these insane like music remixes and
and not just like anime obviously you
know that anime remixes like everyone's
seen the [ __ ] random circulation
yeah yeah or whatever right my friend
sent me one the other day which was
[ __ ] insane it was september by earth
wind and fire oh
remixed with crazy train by ozzy
osbourne
you can remix that song with anything
though yeah but it sounded
[ __ ] amazing i was like oh my god i i
need more i need more i have never seen
an earth wounded fire remix uh september
that disappointed me except for the
taylor swift one that was terrible
but earth winning fire goes in
everything that we the wii shop one have
you seen that the wii
shop bro that [ __ ] collapsed bro
i can't do
i've recently fallen into the rabbit
hole of just listening to j-pop that
they sound like anime opening and
endings but they're not
oh yeah yeah like polka dots
um it's it's it's it's so many yeah
there's
it's like the rabbit hole right you
discover one that the algorithm is like
oh oh you like this
oh hello hello let me let me show you
more it's going so deep right
that recently i was recommended a video
which is kind of like a it was kind of
like a vocaloid kind of remix but i
think it was original song but
the video had no title yeah and the
channel
the channel had no title and then i
click on it what yeah yeah yeah
so so it's it's it's not it's not even
like they have a space or something no
there's just literally no character for
the title
you can do that apparently you can
there's a there's a thing called like a
half half space or something and it's a
space that uh
is technically a character yeah but it
doesn't show up as anything
oh wow so so but but you can't you can't
like highlight it and copy and paste
into the search bar
there's no interaction with whatever
character they're putting down right
right
so the only way people would have got
this
is through recommendations yeah and the
video has like two million views
and then you click i click on it right
and then everyone's like
ah welcome to the cult i see you're
diagnosed
i see you have been the chosen one and
it's it's it's great because like
they're probably going to kill me now
because it was like
everyone's like mutually agreed not to
talk about this which sorry guys i guess
i guess the entire the entire [ __ ]
the entire [ __ ] internet knows now
but i'm not going to link to it
if if you're part if you're part of the
chosen one like
show me a message if i see anyone
linking it i'm gonna [ __ ] ban you
you played me this at your house and i
was just hoping one day it would pop up
in my record
still waiting still waiting still wait
it's like illuminati man you just gotta
wait for that
crappy
no but that's that's just the wonders of
the algorithm i mean i have no idea how
the algorithm works there's
there's okay going completely off topic
here but there's been one video
one video of mine recently oh yeah
that's just been
[ __ ] getting recommended to everyone
and i have
no idea why it's an eight-year-old video
that we've not talked about in this
podcast so many people have tweeted us
about it i'm just like
wow yeah so there's been a video
recently that's been circulating that's
called
recently the time of filming yeah
recently at the time of filming um it
might still be circulating talking about
it it's probably going to start getting
exactly
yeah so i should probably circle back to
the start of annie tube itself you guys
are about to get a history lesson here
go on
so okay so do you do you guys know who
the very first annie tuber is
i thought it was mr anime yeah that was
my preconception yeah
i mean i'd be surprised if anyone
watching this new because that means
you've been around for as long as me
but the very first anime youtuber is
this guy called
hard anime reviews okay and he would be
he started in 2006 and he would just
basically make he would basically make
very uh
very basic anime reviews with like his
camera was like up here
worst angle yeah yeah yeah the kind of
kind of like the worst angle you can
think of the angle we all start
and he he's not he's now quit um it's
it's funny because i
i tried to search him up and see if he's
still around and he
his first his first original channel got
terminated as everyone's did
back then when they're reviewing anime
and his second channel
is called unironically the hard mode
he called it the hard mode and okay if
you search this on youtube you have to
you have to search
the hard mode no space otherwise you're
not going to find it because it's
it's it's like that buried within the
search search algorithm
but the second annie tuber was this
person called mr anime
and um he was he basically made his
anime youtube channel
to compete with hard because hard was
the only anime youtube channel around
and then mr anime was the second one and
he really at the time he really was
one of the big faces of anime youtube
and i say big
he had like a thousand subscribers
that's that's what i mean [ __ ] though
back in the day yeah
that is big [ __ ] back in 2006 2007. yeah
yeah yeah
and then it was after mr anime that
there were like there were like
some some other anime channels here and
there but those two
are basically the founding fathers of
anitu okay
there we we have we have them to thank
for where we are now basically if people
know
the ending to the story then you know
how funny that statement is
i know right so then after a while
i um i make my youtube channel and i
i do i do my own thing and the very very
first shout out i got
was from a mr anime video and it's it's
still up
which video is it huh it's it's mr anime
it's it's
his channel store yeah his channel what
it's all you can view
his entire history and everything that
he did wow that's weird because
who's that guy recently who got
prosecuted for like child pornography
and they took down his channel like that
oh really yeah that austin guy the
singing guy picture on screen
uh yeah i don't know because i
remember a couple of months ago uh i it
a mr anime video like popped up wow wow
just randomly yeah anyway yeah sorry
yeah yeah no so mr anime the first time
he shouted me out was just he made a
video that i called
i think it was called like the face of
annie any tube or anime youtube or
something and he just shouted out a
bunch of
og anime reviews back in the day what a
nice yeah
so so so that was the very first boost
in subscribers i got
i remember messaging him being like oh
thanks a lot man they're like that that
really helps me out they got me like 300
subscribers
like holy [ __ ] that was that was a lot
back and that was a lot yeah i think
that was the video that pushed me over
my first thousand subscribers
nice which was a big which was a big
[ __ ] deal so i was i was really happy
and i really respected the guy as well
because
you know he was if if not if not for him
if not for him like i probably you know
i'd probably be less confident to do
what i did on
like yeah and especially
you know no matter what whenever you see
someone bigger than you shouting you out
that's that's like a big pat on the back
oh yeah
yeah yeah i did well so i was like are
you messing with me back being like nah
that's no problem bro like
i just love i just like i just really
like your stuff you know congratulations
he couldn't even pronounce my name back
then i think in the video he called me
guy gig
no don't say that now they're all gonna
call you guys the subreddit is just like
new material
so that was the last kind of interaction
i had with him
um and that's your first and last
interaction yeah that was that was my
first and last interaction
back then the anime youtube community
wasn't we knew we bought each other but
we didn't
talk about talk to each other that much
it's just before like the msm days
yes yeah yes so it there wasn't an easy
way to talk to each other apart from
back when youtube had messaging you know
i remember
remember those days remember yeah
youtube dms
which were slowly just phased out of
existence i guess
and just nobody remembers that you could
message you could dm people on youtube
but one day um i
just i just woke up and i had this
message from this other anime youtuber
who was called iko arisaka 420 who's
also like
you remember that like yeah yeah yeah
jesus christ i know the entire history
of anime youtube right
right here right here um and he he was
like
he he was he asked me if i'd heard about
this article that's been
like linked around and it was this
article
that was this police report that
basically just said
trey sessler has been arrested for
the murdering his family i'm like yeah
well well is
is is this trey sessler the anime man
the same trace tesla
um [ __ ] i've just blanked in his actual
name now
all that's coming to mind is this mr
anime oh my god
i can't believe i blanked on the name
mid-story
but um why did you doubt me like that
come on yeah yeah i i clicked on the
article and he had his face
and that was just the just the oh [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah is is this is this real
like how how i
i had like 50 different emotions yeah i
kind of just see him because
you don't know how to react to this
because the more i read
just the more sickening it got yeah so
the the entire the entire story
was that apparently traceless trey
sessler mr anime
had uh been playing around with his
brother
and they they were playing around with
guns as they did on that as they did
see he had a lot of guns in in like his
channel and everything but
you know me back then me back then i
just think
americans guns that's what just that's
just what they do
that's what british people think about
it yeah yeah we literally think
americans just walk around be like i
don't know
so he would just have guns in his anime
reviews i just thought that was
completely normal which
you know because he was from texas as
well he was from texas
like sling in texas yeah exactly so i
was like this is this is completely
normal this is nothing to worry about
and
you know there's a texan watching studio
with that gun just like yeah
even even now even now i see a text him
with a gun
i just think you know that's that's even
normal even after everything i'm just
about to experience but i i read the
story and he was playing around with his
guns with his brother
and apparently he accidentally shot his
brother and he and he and he killed him
and so he didn't the the official story
that he gave was he didn't want
his parents to feel guilt or his family
to feel
guilt about you know having his having
their
son kill one of their brothers so he
just apparently he just thought might as
well [ __ ] kill them all
which is which is [ __ ] awful
which is which is [ __ ] awful which is
a [ __ ] awful conclusion to come to so
apparently he kills
his entire family and then and then
it gets worse because the like the more
information that comes out
the more um we find out that he was
actually
not only planning to kill his family
anyway
but he was actually planning a columbine
style
school shooting yeah right i i've
because i saw like this really good
documentary on youtube i'm sure it's up
there still
rainbot right yeah i think so it's it's
basically covers the whole thing but
that's how i got all my information as
well where yeah he was planning to do a
school shooting and
he i did he post about it online that he
was going to do it or something like
that but he basically
was on the way to the school and that's
when he got arrested yeah yeah
no because he was he was planning he was
planning the school shooting for way
before he's killed his family because i
think
i think how he thought was he killed his
brother by accident
but he was always planning the school
shooting anyway yeah like
he had he had it all mapped out and
everything so in between that he
accidentally killed his brother and
killed his family and that's what outed
him
but he was always planning this and
there's this really ominous video
um it was i think it's the second to
last mr anime video that's on his
channel that's just called
mr anime is planning something
i remember watching that thinking ah
he's taking a break from any chief i'm
just planning a new review he's he's
planning a car he's planning a comeback
but i don't know it's it because he
talks about anime in that video so he
might he might have been just
purely talking about anime but i'm like
with all the information
i have we have now he's probably now
that was [ __ ] scary
[ __ ] that title was [ __ ] yeah and
the more information that come that came
out the more i just
didn't know how to process this because
how how do you process the fact that
one of the people you looked up to and
respected just [ __ ] killed their
family and was planning to shoot up a
[ __ ] school
like what what what what'd you do with
that yeah and
that bothered me for uh for for like a
for a while and i remember that's this
was the time i was at university and
people were like why why is
why does ghan look like someone just die
in his family or something
but i i think the way the best way i can
describe it is
imagine if you like live in a small town
and you you may be like you know
everyone in that small town you might
not be friends with everyone in that
small town but you feel like this
small tight-knit community and then you
find that someone in this small tiny
community
has done something awful yeah it's like
something that's
not like beyond words you know beyond
words awful and it's
and then to try to process
process this i i made the video
which is being recommended now it's
circulating everywhere
even though it's eight years old um it's
for some reason youtube decided yep
people want to see gang reacting to mr
anime murdering his family
i i don't i don't know how that came
about it's literally on everyone's
recommendation it was on my recommended
yeah i don't know why like yeah it's
probably not monetized right
no no it's not money right so it's just
like it just goes against
everything about the youtube algorithms
like it's not monetized it's about a
horrible tragedy it's about a very
sensitive topic i mean i'm eight years
old i i think i
uploaded this before even like the
monetization thing like started on
youtube or at least before i was
monetized because i was
i had like a thousand plus subscribers
back then so
it was it wasn't massive i remember as
well that i
i i remember stumbling upon a mr anime
video
even like way before i knew about the
whole anime youtubing sphere and
everything
because it was mr anime's review
on gantz that made me want to go watch
games
and uh wow this guy's got a bright
career yeah and i was like wow this
guy's like really fun he [ __ ] had
do you know how ghetto his setup was he
he had like a a a
webcam or something yeah yeah to record
and he was sitting on his bed and he had
his lap it was like a notepad oh it was
like an apple an
apple notebook it was like an apple
notepad of the script and he was
literally just looking down
at the apple notepad just reading off
the script and then every now and then i
guess
because he didn't know how to edit his
videos so instead he had
a remote that controlled the zoom of the
lens
he controlled the zoom of the lens and
just start talking to the camera and
then he just zoomed back out
yeah yeah no cuts so he was like i
remember in the gantz review
he was talking about uh you know the
acid scene right yeah in the dance anime
and how he was like it made me go and
then he stops and zooms in
and zooms really far into his face and
he goes [ __ ]
and then he zooms out with a dead face
and it just goes back to reading it
yeah and that was the review no cuts no
edits
and i was like yeah i want to watch this
anime
that was quality content back in the day
or youtube i remember when
i started coming out with my videos i
was one of the first to actually just
use an editing software even though it
was just putting images over whatever
i'm saying i was like people were like
what he's he's using windows movie maker
impossible
wow but uh yeah that's that's the story
of
the first person i ever in like humble
beginnings
yeah that's so fun yeah but i i
recommend like as [ __ ]
of uh of a topic that is like i i
definitely recommend that
documentary on youtube that somebody
made it's great because it perfectly
goes through
everything about it and at the end of
the documentary i don't know how they
got this footage but
there's this the police footage the
police footage yeah of how he's in like
the jail cell yeah
yeah the interview that [ __ ] is so scary
man yeah
and to think this is the guy who founded
basically what i do for a living i know
i know right right like that's so
[ __ ] scary
it's it's so weird because i've had a
con i've had this conversation with a
few people and
we just think man there's a lot of [ __ ]
that's happened in any tubes yeah yeah
right
i think there's stuff that unfortunately
you know happens in every community yeah
and that
we probably will never find out some
really [ __ ] up [ __ ] that people have
done oh yeah
i mean we've only recently found out
about a lot of it right right
right i mean you know you you it's it's
really unfortunate because we don't like
to think that we know people who are
like
that but if time's proven anything it's
that
you know i've i've met people and been
friendly with people who have done
really [ __ ] horrible stuff i'm sure i
mean i never knew that you know one of
my best friends used to
punch kids in the face right
i mean once you look once you look up
and respect a [ __ ]
serial killer school shooter then it's
all downhill from there right
yeah exactly i know how it feels to see
a police report and being like oh
no oh yeah i i i just
it's just a mess of emotions it's first
it's
surely this is fake yeah because you see
it and you're like i've never seen a
police before first of all
yeah yeah this could easily be doctored
like yeah yeah
and then just seeing like all the counts
being slowly like added and you're like
oh no
yeah oh no oh no this is bad yeah and i
think that
that was the first time because i had a
conversation with
aiko the the anime review about how we
should process this and remember him
saying
um yeah i think he just he'll keep the
the memories of mr anime like the same
but it's just he has to view mr anime
and trey sessler as like different
people and i think that was the first
time
the first time i i had just thought
about the entire process of
having to view online personalities as
different
in person how they portray this the
whole thing of like separating the
artist from the creation yeah yeah
exactly right
it's and yeah the it was more the fact
that this happened in our small
community as well because
right it's like happening in like the
small back rural town right where
nothing happens
because i'm sure now in any tube i'm
sure there's some [ __ ] somewhere
oh there's probably some someone doing
so we don't despicable [ __ ] that we
don't know about you know but
it they weren't a figurehead in this
very small community yeah they weren't
the [ __ ] founding father
the literal founding the literal
founding the more the more you say that
out loud the more i'm like
oh the founding fathers tend to normally
be sketchy
how how do we sell that the anime
youtube community is like this really
cool thing
oh the family father's a serial killer
that's a conversation starter i like to
think of it of you know
it's it's one of those things that was
going to be started anyway
eventually around that time right it
just so happened that he was the first
or
one of the first maybe that's the reason
why nobody used
anime in the username until i came up
because people because i know for a fact
that some of my early videos
man those comments were just like the
anime man i thought that guy went to
jail
like they legitimately mistook me for
mystery who would res who
who would mistake you for that yeah
better run rewind that
flash back to five minutes ago
yeah so but like you know i obviously
didn't know
about that news until after i started uh
my youtube channel because i think
what year was it that he got arrested um
i mean it was eight years ago
i think that's the only reason i
remember this is because the youtube
video has been recommended is eight
years ago so what's like 2012
right probably yeah something like 2011
2012 it was probably just a really bad
time there because i started 2013 right
literally right after it happened yeah i
didn't know about it until i
started it and i had like a decent
following and i was like oh [ __ ] i can't
go back now
like i can't change my name now i should
have i should have changed so what was
like the early years of anime youtube
like then
like and like so you that was over like
what well how long you've been new
youtube before 12 years did you say
um since 2007. okay so how was the anime
so how was the another spear from 2007
to 2012.
it was like slow right it was very slow
so before 2012 which is which is i kind
of like where
i think you came along um it was
the quality was not good obviously um
as as it is but it was it was it was fun
i don't know
i i kind of in in a way i'm going to
sound so boomer saying this but i kind
of miss
old youtube where kind of anything went
always look
back fondly at the time when it was
smaller yeah more manageable because it
was more intimate
yeah yeah and you always look back at
that period especially on youtube right
so i'm sure you all
missed the time and you made like one
thousand you could just talk to random
people
no no you're like wow you're so cool
yeah you know i remember i made a video
when i hit a thousand subscribers and i
thought i'd made it i thought
i thought mom i'm dropping everything
dude i i swear like i've always said
this to people but
the joy of hitting a thousand
subscribers is
almost comparable to hitting like a
hundred thousand or a million
subscribers yeah yeah yeah because a
thousand is just like whoa because a
thousand is like
monumental it is because it's a number
that is
very easily like quantifiable yeah but
it's also
huge because like thinking like wow
there's a thousand people who like me
yeah because once it gets to like a
million
it's it's it starts to become something
that you just can't really comprehend
yeah like physically
whereas a thousand is like holy [ __ ] i'm
popular i'm [ __ ] popular and that
back then it was just
it was you know as it grew into it was
all about doing anime reviews and
a lot of people had different styles if
you came in with an editing software you
you were just
you were just you were the goat
otaku and tristan glass reflection
reflection came along and they used
sony vegas to edit that video and it
[ __ ]
blew my it blew my mind they used a paid
price
yeah just some of the stuff they could
get away with that i couldn't
using like putting images on windows
movie maker what the [ __ ]
it was basically a glorified powerpoint
yeah yeah
but i think my favorite anime review
from back then was this guy called uh
grumpy g-sun
i [ __ ] love him i do not know this
he's so
good yeah yeah he he's an og and he
doesn't make videos anymore but
what he do is that he'd he'd do anime
reviews but
he'd do it in like the middle of some a
desert in arizona somewhere
right he would review an anime while
like hiking through the dish yeah yeah
yeah
so so what so he was like he was he was
basically pre
casey neistat because what he'd do he'd
always start off
his videos with like uh with like uh
uh with him walking towards the camera
in like the middle of the desert so what
he would have to do
is that he would have to set up his
camera
hike like hike away off screen and then
[ __ ]
hike back into view of the camera it
wasn't it wasn't like he was hiking a
short distance he would be literally
like hiking over hills and mountains
sometimes to get to the camera
and yeah he how long was his intro like
just two minutes
because it was just like super sped up
and you just see him walking towards the
camera so you it would be like
it'd be like it would be like a squirrel
just like scurrying like towards the
camera
and he's like today we're going to talk
about berserk
this sounds amazing as well how a lot of
his reviews he he always had like a
place to go right so he would start
with at the front of the trail being
like today we're going to talk about you
know hunter hunter
and then as he's walking he would talk
about the show and then usually
the one i saw i forgot which anime it
was but he was hiking up this mountain
yeah and
i don't he must have like perfectly
timed this [ __ ] like he must have done
the hike beforehand because
the moment he got to the top was when he
finished his conclusion on the show
yeah and he was just like i've made it
to the top guys and that's the end of my
review yeah
i'm like that's [ __ ] like all right
like thinking back because
thinking back it was it was very
different from what everyone was doing
we were just like
huh old man reviewing anime that's
pretty weird but thinking back he was
a lot of his ideas were really cool you
know he's kind of ahead of his time
he was definitely ahead of his time yeah
and that's that's why he stands out to
me apart from the guy who [ __ ] killed
himself i guess
no no no not killed himself killed
someone else um
but yeah it's it was kind of like the
wild west back then
i mean all of you i mean it wasn't the
internet the wild yeah what's the so if
that's the first era right where you're
like
you know 2007 2012 what came after that
what's like the era
um what years are we talking between
cause i'm interested
i didn't start till 2015. so all of it
before that is like
yeah i'd say around about i can't
remember exactly when it was founded but
that was that was kind of like the wild
west of youtube where
everyone was kind of doing their own
things it was it was a mess of different
things
and then 2012 was kind of what like
where the annie tube community really
started to form into this one
one conglomerate and i think the big the
big
event that happened was probably potaku
potaku was huge
yeah that's the first time i recognized
anyone outside of you
yeah and i was like oh there's other
people yeah and i remember because i was
always i was already uh so we had four
original members there was
holden reviews um jean who were who was
originally called x disturbed jeans
and uh tristan the glass reflection and
i remember what started it was
tristan one day messaged me out
messaging me out the blue with the
youtube dm's being like hey do you want
to talk about
this new anime season and this was
before
this was before i'd even started
watching seasonal anime this was this
before
this was before the concept of hey you
can watch anime weekly and be hyped for
seasonal anime you know
yes i'm pretty sure you made a joke in
one of your videos where it's like why
would i want to come
over the space of 12 weeks when i could
just come in one big go
that was a joke you made and i
remembered that sorry i completely
forgot about that
that's an amazing joke for some reason
that stuck with me and i was like that's
a
that's a great example i would i would
like to come in one go
no no i'm thinking about my thought
process and
my like what the thought process is why
would i want a 12th of an orgasm when i
could just have one
orgasm in one session yeah right that's
such a good joke
yeah and so we so we've
we've made this podcast which wasn't
even a podcast
um it was it was kind of just a recorded
skype call
and we didn't know where to put it so i
made the suggestion to put it on youtube
because this was
this was before like it was an audio
podcast it wasn't a visual podcast like
this so nobody
thought that putting audio podcasts on
youtube would work and i just i was just
like well we're youtubers so why not
why why not put it on youtube right and
yeah it was
i i don't like saying it like this
because it kind of sounds like it's like
sucky mundic or whatever but
but i would say like potaku was a big
factor in you know shaping the anime the
anime youtube community
of that time no absolutely i think it
left as somebody who
you know wasn't even interested in being
an anime youtuber i definitely shaped i
think how i
felt about it because at the time i was
listening to pottaku like every week
like i never even i never wanted to be a
youtuber never
crossed my mind but definitely when i
got into it i think a lot of the
influences came from
listening to that so i think you may not
have shaped the generation you were in
but you definitely helped shape the one
that came after i mean there's
definitely
you know a reason why even to this day
people who are around in the anime
yeah people back then still are like
yeah remember pod taco like
like even people who didn't watch pod
taku knew pod taco yeah i mean it was a
it's
it's still a big point in my life otaku
really really was it
i i think back to portage very fondly
even though it's like ended now and i've
moved on
in my life it had he had a big part of
shaping me as a person and
it's especially because portugal was the
first ever friends i made
that i could talk to anime with yeah you
know i mean that that goes all the way
back to the
conversation we had at the start but
holden and jean were literally
the first people i was able to bond over
anime with
and potaku was kind of like my weekly
bi-weekly
kind of session where i could just nerd
over and i would just
with your buddies yeah exactly yeah and
apparently a lot of people
looked up to us back then because a lot
of people apparently didn't
also have friends to talk to anime
without listening and
um and so that really i feel like that
cemented the next era of anime youtube
before i think i think you came along
and i think that was
that was kind of the era of youtube
where it was i think it was a last era
where people could just
make content without a monetary
incentive in mind
right right right because everyone ever
we did we did poor taku not because we
were getting paid we weren't getting
paid for it at all
for a lot of it um we we basically made
it because we just wanted two
projects it was a passion it's it was it
was kind of like this
but back then this was before we had any
kind of monetization yeah
we we were just we were just four mates
who would just go go on a skype call
um and record the audio and just splice
it together and upload it on youtube and
then i came in when the fat chicks
started rolling
no but like i i don't think it's too
much to say that
you know this podcast included there's a
lot of anime podcasts now right yeah
yeah exactly
big and small and i don't think it'd be
too far to say that
you know pod taco is probably the one
who
probably got the train rolling in that
side of attitude it it kind of amazes me
because like before
this before this came along before trash
chase came along
um you look back to some of the views
and you know
popularity of potaku and it still
basically holds up
almost to a lot of the bigger podcasts
that
came after it i mean there's only a few
podcasts that i can think of
that came after potaku that animated
yeah
anime related that were able to you know
do better in it with it in terms of
views and
views and stuff and potaka is like six
years old now so that that
kind of that kind of blows my mind you
want to hear a glass from the past sure
warning the following audio may contain
course language
and other material that may not be
suitable for a younger audience
viewer discretion is advised that is
screaming
dude there's like maybe a couple of
hundred people watching this right now
who just cream their
nostalgia that that intro is like
ingrained in my minds man
that your accent warning is
so you have been warned if you go to my
channel the very very first video
is like a podcast that looks very
reminiscent of the editing style of
another podcast oh really oh really
it looks very very similar with the the
cubes flashing up between
oh yeah yeah oh yeah um because yeah who
did you edit all of them
um no so originally it was basically
between me and tristan
and holden who had to edit most of the
podcast and so we we basically edited
the audio so they would sync up and
we would remove a lot of like when you
have calls on skype
people talking over each other yeah
people talking over each other and you
have this
really awkward pause where it's where
it's you cut it all up smoothly yeah
yeah
exactly and then we were like we wanted
to make it a bit more visual
so but we couldn't we we couldn't just
film ourselves next to each other
so we kind of just decided to go with
flashing boxes yeah it works really well
yeah yeah and that was that was our way
of just evolving the podcast
and um i remember after poor taku we
kind of added
a few more people as well right i want
to ask about that because i was when as
a viewer i was so confused there was
just people
like towards the end would just start
joining in
and then i was like jay taku and i'm
like what is what is going on with all
of this
was jimmy on the podcast yeah jimmy
right nice
it was so odd because it just seemed
like people were just recycling in and i
was like wait
this is not what i want i wanted the
boys
i'm on the big fallback you know like as
a viewer i was so confused i don't think
you guys like ever explain any of that
right yeah so i mean
i'd be interested in knowing well for me
it was because the scheduling just got
super hard
because like i said we weren't getting
paid for anything so this was this was
just us
making time making making time and we
got to a point with potaku where we were
having a [ __ ] hard time keeping up
with this two-week schedule
so i i wanted to and it had been a while
since potako started so i wanted to
spice things up
um and i wanted to see if there was like
we could get some chemistry with other
people
and that's when i brought on the idea of
jaitaku
and adding more people and making making
a distinct brand of potaku is where we
just talk about
pure whatever we want to talk about it's
kind of like a free-flowing podcast and
jaitaku
is we're going to pick a specific topic
and we're going to stay on top right
right
and that was that was the kind of idea
of jaetaku it was it kind of hit
everything because it added some new
elements to the podcast
and it also made it so less of a load
was on the original four as well
um but yeah it's it's interesting to
hear what you guys thought about it as a
viewer perspective i think
because i didn't watch every single one
and then
i think i just saw like three j takus
and i was so confused
then i watch it i'm like who are half of
these people yeah like
yeah it's so strange and i think i think
what um it was
it really worked at first because jay
jay taku did his job
and then it got to the point when
jaetaku kind of even maybe
became the flagship series because if
you look on if you look on the potaku
channel
a lot of the most viewed videos ended up
being jaitaku
originally videos like our most viewed
video
was one where we literally just talk
about hentai nice
of course know but that that was that
was back when
talking about him hentais are like very
hush-hush
nobody likes nobody publicly liked
hentai on twitter
or any any [ __ ] like that allowed me to
introduce myself
hi but um yeah so jaitaku kind of became
one of the flagship series um because it
just got more views and
the main like the main the original four
people it just became harder and harder
for us to schedule
um schedule schedule with the original
pataku
yeah yeah podcast um and i think that's
kind of
that's that's kind of what brought like
helped
bring portugal to an end because i i
feel like
i feel like that era of anitube is
defined by the start of potaku and the
end of pataku because i think the other
thing
the end of potaku really it
coincidentally coincided with a lot of
the times when
you know joey really rose and people
realized they could do anime content for
money as well yeah
which just wasn't an idea before then
and
i remember i mean should i talk about
the end of photography
go ahead if you want man we could edit
it are we about to do this now
am i gonna am i really gonna bring this
up but it's up to you bro
okay so i guess i've never i've never
talked about this but we've
we've obviously gotten a lot of comments
about potako on this podcast
on this podcast and uh it was we i don't
think anyone's really publicly talked
about it
and to preface this still love still
love everyone on the podcast i'm not
about to talk
mad [ __ ] or anything like that and the
long in the story the long and the short
of it
is that we came into some creative
differences
about which way the podcast could go
because
to me potaku was the defining podcast of
the anitu community as
as i have just said and i really wanted
to push that further i want i wanted to
i wanted it to i wanted portugal to like
evolve more yeah yeah
because i saw the potential in how
big the podcast could be because um the
problem was that
we had trouble keeping up with our
schedule and then we took like a
seven month break or something like that
it was very long i think it was it was a
very long
long day yeah yeah yeah and the reason
for that was
basically the podcast didn't really have
a like a designated leader right leading
in right now so
i've been like at the beginning of the
podcast it was mainly
me and tristan who were getting things
like getting getting things done
chasing up yeah i mean jean loved gene
she was she was like the mother of the
group but she was like she would like
come in and out
because she was very busy with her real
life holden [ __ ] talented as
[ __ ] talented guy but it was you know
i i know i've told this told him before
you know it's it's
unless you unless you tell if you tell
holden to do something
he'll [ __ ] do it if you don't he
won't do it if you don't he's not the
type of
he wasn't the type of person that would
like push people to do it you know
and you know i think he's changed now
for the better and i think potaka was
definitely a big learning experience for
him as well so i think
he's definitely grown as a person but
back then it was mainly
it was mainly me and tristan who was
pushing stuff to get done on the podcast
and
tristan started to get less and less
involved because
he started to transition doing
anime reviews as a hobby to actually
finally getting paid for it because he
had opened his patreon he was the only
one that was actively doing vid
videos companies that was at the time
when tristan was like really at his peak
yeah yeah he was like really growing at
that time exactly i remember his patreon
was a big deal yeah yeah yeah exactly
because
he was the only one who was who had
other commitments for his own youtube
channel
so he just had less time than all of us
and then
for me that was also the time when i got
my job at the bbc
right right so you saw you see all these
factors coming into play where
the driving force of the podcasts just
had
less time to really make episodes and
people in jaitarki we were all good
friends
but they were you know they weren't the
original four they
were they weren't the og4 they didn't
really have the i'd say authority to
really take over
yeah you can't really step in and be
like this is mine yeah yeah yeah exactly
so we basically took a seven seven month
hiatus or it's it's it's a hiatus but it
was more of not nothing was getting done
yeah i i won't said anything nothing was
really happening
they left you on red
and it was basically because we just
didn't have the time
and what what was the driving force for
it to be revamped was i that was the
point when i
wanted to return to youtube i was
getting bored of my job
and i was like okay first step i want to
put all my hard work into potaku and
really revamping this because
tristan's doing really well with
whatever he's doing
with this patreon and i saw potential
for not only
me coming back but also pushing poor
taku into something even bigger and
better than what it was yeah
with help formerly you know trying to
monetize it and they just
basically making it have an incentive
for everyone to turn up every week
exactly right
exactly and so it ended up being i was
the
big driving force to getting potaki back
on his feet and that's why i got
super super invested in it because i was
the one who was
getting trying to get episodes done i
was editing a lot of them
not because i wanted to be paid or
anything but i just wanted
this to you what you wanted your passion
to be i wanted i wanted my passion to be
back on the ground yeah
and as as soon as
i felt it was kind of getting back off
the ground
i remember tristan coming coming to me
and he was like i
i want it to end you know what i mean
right yeah and
um i looking back now i totally
understand
why he did right because this this is
where this is where i
i put it back to creative differences
because
he saw that we weren't getting as many
views as we used to before the hiatus
right and also the dynamic of the group
was
very different than when than when we
started
you know some people weren't getting
along as well as
as as uh as they were
they were at the beginning so he wanted
potaku to just end there you know yeah
yeah
he he wanted to be like okay instead of
just fizzling fizzling out
um i wanted to end here and i really
really tried to convince him to be like
look i know we're going through some
very big issues now
but i see potential in this yeah there
was there was a lot of there was a lot
of factors
that i saw that could potentially have
driven
a lot of hype back into botaku um before
we ended that we had um
jean had just left yeah right but she
was she was going to come back we had
scheduled that
we had also scheduled mintaku too which
is the hentai episode which was like our
most
popular one right so i was like look
it's we can do it we can do the combo
plea i like i i i really really tried to
convince him that it was too early to
end yeah because i
i totally agree with all the problems
that the podcast had
if in order to survive and to go further
we would have had to
make a lot of big changes and they could
have very easily blown up in our face i
guess it's one of those things where
it's like
you could try but you could very easily
fail so it's one of those things where
you're like do i want to put in this
work and i can get the guaranteed pages
yeah why really yeah
right like i kind of get it but at the
same time i i'm like
as a viewer i knew how like big it could
have been as well yeah looking in my
position now and i understand how it all
works like
yeah it could have been i think it could
have been certainly yeah definitely it
would have needed a lot of work and it
would have take we would have taken a
big risk and we could have failed
massively but for me as a person i would
rather
give that a go right right right one
yeah then wonder
and it got to the point when it was just
it was just like it was just this one
clash
right of just i wanted i i thought it
was too early to end it
and tristan wanted to wanted to end it
yeah and it was it was unfortunate
that you know you know i i i say
unfortunately i didn't i didn't get my
way
he didn't listen to me i tried i tried
so hard there was a video that you guys
all made when it ended right and i
remember watching this and it was like
one of those moments you're like please
say psych
please say sorry jk lol but i remember
watching that video and it like
because i remember the order was like
you first and it was like tristan was
last
yeah yeah and i i tristan i love tristan
by the way just saying
but i remember watching and i was
thinking like man it kind of seems like
everyone was like really wanting to keep
doing this but then
tristan didn't almost as a viewer it
wasn't like that it was
at the end as a viewer i think that's
the impression yeah like it could be
totally wrong just an impression i mean
there was definitely a faction that
supported
my stance right there was the faction
that supported tristan's stance i mean
look like as someone who creates now i
can understand both yeah
i don't care about either i mean it's
definitely a tough decision right now oh
yeah
yeah anybody in that position would have
been like ah [ __ ] do i take the risk or
not at the end of the day if his heart's
not in it his heart's not in it right
yeah exactly
if you're going to like drag someone
along he doesn't want to do it yeah you
can't like
so was there no option to just do it
without tristan
i mean we we we wanted to respect
tristan's wishes because we there was
there was the conversation of like
um should we do this without tristan you
know but
it just it just felt wrong yeah just
understandable
because i i wanted to leave the option i
asked tristan would it be okay
if we continued and then you know
at any point if forever for whatever
whatever reason you want to return the
doors are
always open yeah and tristan was like
elements no i don't
and i understand because this was his
baby
no i don't feel comfortable letting my
baby go and just seeing what happens
yeah so that's that's that's kind of
that
that was kind of like the the last draw
you know
there was no there was no going back
from that and yeah that's
basically how it ended and it was after
that
that um i i kind of lost a lot of
motivation because i put
so much of myself into getting this
revamped
and it just felt like it was just all
taken away and it was out of my control
and it i learned a lot from potaku with
like learning working on group projects
and everything like that
and i should probably and i want to say
i'm not throwing shade at tristan at all
we still get along great
yeah we all get electricity yeah yeah i
i i love tristan
it was just it was just a point where we
just had creative differences
and it happens i feel that's a very
normal thing
people i've what i'm trying to say is
i've really got to demonize and like
don't
yeah yeah yeah i'm i'm not demonizing
tristan i
like we just had a different way of
approaching things i
you know i still think back to portugal
and i still think hey
i think it ended too early and he
obviously thinks the other way and he
thought the other way back then and
that's
basically what it was how it is man yeah
that's just how it is yes
obviously we don't want anyone going and
being like what the [ __ ] man why don't
you why don't you not believe in it man
i mean like
like like i said earlier like if your
heart's on it your heart's not in it
right yeah it's not gonna happen i mean
can anyone like really blame tristan
like again it's it's a [ __ ] like i
would have
really if it's liberating as well right
if i didn't believe in it i'm normally
someone who's like adamant about [ __ ]
right so i would be like no
no yeah i don't believe in this yeah
like i would be like that yeah
exactly so it's you know it's just how
it is right yeah yeah yeah and i mean
yeah i mean i always look back to think
you know what
what could what could it be what could
be but that was that was just the end of
an era
and now we're in a new era and i'm you
know everyone's gone down the different
paths i
i'm really amazed to see what people are
getting onto nowadays and it's it's
[ __ ] great and i'm still
you know i still speak to all the cast
members every now and again especially
when we get to meet at conventions
hey bottom line is that at least there
isn't a single member of paul tucker
that went and killed their family
well that's a taker
they didn't they didn't go down to mr
anime around all right let's just
that's the silver lining
80s outro where it tells you what we've
all been up to
the [ __ ] snapshot it's like yeah
joey didn't kill his family jesus christ
oh my god that's a [ __ ] tape oh my
god
okay okay before we end it right like i
guess
the way i see it right is if you were
still doing you know potaku trash taste
probably wouldn't exist
yeah that's that's true that's what i'm
saying i'm not trying to say you know
that it's it's you know i'm i'm glad
that your passion project [ __ ] died
but i'm glad that we have this you know
no i'm i'm very glad as well please
don't kill your families
[Music]
just just gonna throw that out there you
know
i'm british how do i get a gun i don't
even know how to get it right how do you
do that
walmart i don't want to have to make a
twit longer that's like
so about connor oh no
my thoughts on sea dog vp
oh this is going to be real ironic if
you kill your family jerry in the wake
up
we should have seen the signs all along
it was in the name
oh my god it it kind of felt that when
potaku ended that it kind of like
it's like tearing down the berlin wall
right yeah just letting everyone [ __ ]
loose right because i feel like
when a big pillar and a community kind
of you know kind of falls right it's
just like
just a ton of people come free for all
right basically yeah like it's kind of
like everyone's looking for the new like
all right who's the person i'm gonna
listen to
yeah like we don't really have that at
the moment i don't feel
anything we have a few big people but i
feel that that's when
definitely you said the new era just was
like all right yeah yeah
hi because back then it was all about
doing anime reviews
and then it i i would say the content
started to
really like it kind of like opened the
doors to all different kind of content
like you're doing
more vloggy videos and analytical
channels start to come along
so i i feel you know it was it was a
coincidence that it happened during the
end of partaku but i feel like
for our community that was that was a
big turning point
oh definitely yeah absolutely because i
remember that was when demos
demo came along as well i think so
nearly enough back then when you were
saying and he [ __ ]
changed the game as well oh no
definitely like there is i don't think
there's a single lander tube
that's on the platform right now and no
longer on the platform who
didn't look up the demo yeah in any if
you do stuff yeah
if you did anime stuff like demo was
just a name that came back right he's
like the dad that went to go buy
cigarettes and just never came back
right
i'm glad i i came into it when i did
right i feel like i came into it at the
time where
it's perfect because it was where i
wanted to make the content i wanted to
make right yeah
i think you came at a perfect time
because it was around the time when the
whole anime youtube thing
really diversified itself in terms of
its content so
people like you who did very
unconventional anime content it was very
easy to like just slip in
yeah it's great i mean i'm glad that
it's gotten to the point where we can
you know make a set like this
right because like in my mind i didn't
want to do a podcast unless it was
this good yeah right like i just i've no
interest in it like i don't want to do
audio yeah this everyone has an audio
podcast yeah like this this is what i
kind of wanted to push potaku to the
direction of
going like me like we obviously didn't
live in the same place but my idea
was hey what if what what if we all flew
to a place
recorded recorded a ton of episodes yeah
and released it
on a schedule yeah and we could do that
on a periodic basis based on like
whatever funding we
we could have gotten yeah um but i'm
glad that
i have you guys now who yeah
it's taking me how long portuguese 4.0
hey i'm not the one saying that all
right the [ __ ] ton of people in that
first episode were like
this is just toku 2.0 no
i'm hosting next i'm just going to do
that that intro
you have to do it you have to do it
i mean it's it's great man i mean like
you said earlier about the like ambition
of it i think us three really have like
really great ideas of ways that you want
to make this not just a podcast right it
sounds really crazy like the
like the akiba video was just like just
the step in the stuff
i'd like to say i thought up of the
akiva video in the shower
shut the [ __ ] up thank you to our
patrons
for supporting this episode our guys are
freaking awesome if you'd like your name
on the screens as such and other bonuses
then make sure to support us over on
patreon start taking more showers
it's super zen
you know you know what you can start
doing following us on twitter and the
subreddit
which is always in the description below
send us your meme send us your
gig again the showers and anime zones
the best thing about our twitter is that
one of us will make a post and the other
two have to figure out who did it
yeah like the [ __ ] tweet i was like
i was like wow because he was poking fun
at him and he was like i don't know who
did it yeah
in my head i was like which of these
[ __ ]
i signed up to make a tlist account just
for that moment
i haven't made one in my life i like the
commitment that was yeah
for the memes man yeah yeah exactly but
if you'd like to send us your memes then
the twitter and subreddit always open
you guys
send us some [ __ ] dank ass memes over
there i love the
the chess uh manga stuff blowing up
some of the images i've seen you guys
are too talented [ __ ] amazing yeah
has been [ __ ]
yeah but i hope you guys enjoyed this
episode and uh we'll see you guys in the
next we've been the neanderthal
boys the naughty neanderthals no no
these no the viewers of the naughty
neoprene
there is no way we are getting monetized
this episode
worth it for the joke but i've been i've
been your host joey and as always
my co-host scott and connor and we'll
see you guys next time subscribe to my
[Music]
youtube
[Music]
you